à ottawa vous le savez maintenant depuis
ce matin on est passé à une autre étape
la police d'ottawa
accompagné de plus hauts de plusieurs
autres corps policiers a commencé à
lancer cette grande opération pour
dégager la voie publique ottawa faire
partir les manifestants ou les arrêter
il ya deux choix y'en a pas eu 8 depuis
ce matin d'ailleurs on procède méthode
dick mans
avec des chevaux avec des policiers qui
avancent lentement ce sont des images en
direct que vous voyez où la groupe de
policiers devant des manifestants et ont
dit la même chose depuis ce matin soit
que vous quittez soir on vous met les
menottes et qu on vous arrête il ya eu
70 arrestations depuis ce matin il ya 23
camions qui ont déjà été remorqué je
vais vous montrer la carte qu'il faut
comprendre c'est quand même assez gras
c'est pas si grave c'est quand même
assez grains où ça se déroule vous voyez
donc cette zone rouge ottawa pris le
parlement en eau la rue wellington des
rues transversales on a subdivisé cette
zone rouge en une dizaine de sous-hommes
et la police les a numéroté de 1 à 11 et
ce matin dès 7 heures on commençait zone
et qu'est ce qu'on fait on arrête les
gens où on les fait partir une fois que
la zone est libéré ben on ferme avec des
clôtures plus personne qui peut entrer
on va faire ça comme ça au cours des
prochaines heures pour chaque sou zoom
delà de la zone du centre-ville d'ottawa
sébastien saint françois bonsoir bonne
fin d'après midi vous êtes là depuis je
vous ai vu ce matin et hier soir il va
sans dire mais ce matin très tôt
c'est vraiment une une leçon qui pense
qui va avoir un coup d'éclat puis voir
feu d'artifice il va voir on va courir
c'est pas comme ça que cette opération
l'un conçu c'est là c'est méthodique
mais on avance lentement mais sûrement
selon la police
exactement on en avait discuté à
plusieurs reprises sur nos ondes patrice
le problème c'est un casse tête énorme
dans la ville d'ottawa en ce moment
parce que il ya plusieurs intersections
il ya au moins au minimum la quinzaine
d'intersection où il ya une douzaine
voir une vingtaine de camions 10h et 12h
semi remorque des fourgonnettes de toute
sorte et ça c'est intersection par
intersection qu'il faut gagner pour le
pour les policiers vérifier qui a rien
une problématique une fois qu'on a
réussi à déblayer c'est à dire à faire
reculer les gens et ensuite progresser
au delà de cette intersection et faire
remorquer les véhicules qui étaient à
l'intérieur donc ça va être extrêmement
long mais ça a commencé ce matin et ça a
donné lieu à des scènes patrice assez
surprenante parce que ce matin après la
première intersection qui était dégagé
on s'est amené vers la deuxième pour les
policiers à grand renfort d'agents de
contrôle de foule quelques centaines de
policiers sur la promenade colonel by à
ottawa qui vaut jusqu'à la rue rideau
cette rue rideau lakes transforme à
warrington et elle va jusqu'au parlement
et la première intersection des
policiers ont dû gagner ils ont
travaillé fort parce qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de manifestants qui leur
barrait le chemin et les manifestants se
sont interposés physiquement
spécialistes en
scène
très surprenant merci des manifestants
qui brode subra dessous d'eux profond
s'appuyer les uns les autres et aller au
corps à corps avec les policiers
carrément pas de coût ou si peu pas de
grosse bien sûr un policier blessé
blessures mineures étaient sur place on
a vu nous des manifestants se relever
après que les mélismes ce transfèrement
mais se soit transformée en mêlée de
rugby on a vu des participants et des
manifestants se relever en boitant un
peu à quelques reprises plusieurs
arrestations lors probablement une
quinzaine au cours de ces mails et là
mes dessins surprenant parce qu'en
général les manifestants qui se présente
devant les policiers reculent toujours
quand les policiers avancent certaines
personnes qui veulent le passer un
message seul s arrêter mais là on avait
vraiment une résistance qui a duré plus
d'une heure les rangs des manifestants
patrice ils se sont amenuisées à cause
des arrestations mais il ya eu vraiment
confrontation physique en mêlée entre
les manifestants et les policiers à de
nombreuses reprises ont j'en profite cet
intéressant ce que vous racontez parce
que quand même eu des altercations
on verra aussi cette image de cet homme
qui parlait à une amie dans son camion
voulait pas sortir la police a fait au
toc toc toc toc toc pour la troisième
fois il ya cassé la ville puis à sortir
le monsieur on vous montrera les images
donc oui on donne le choix aux gens de
partir mais à un moment donné il y à la
force qui est employé mais le chef steve
bell qui a fait une conférence de presse
une demi-heure dit il n'y a eu
aucun blessé rapportés chez les
manifestants aucun un léger blessés
depuis ce matin chez les policiers c'est
tout donc ça se passe relativement bien
que
oui pour des confrontations entre
manifestants et policiers des policiers
lourdement armés qui sont renforcées non
seulement par une deuxième ligne en
contrôle de foule c'est à dire des gens
d d d d agents qui sont armés entre
autres d'irritants chimiques peut-être
aussi on le présume de balles à
caoutchouc même si on ne s'est pas
officiellement qu'ils sont renforcées au
cid équipe tactique qui sont en
troisième ligne et qui peuvent entrer et
faire des arrestations donc c'est
surprenant et j'oserais presque
miraculeux qui ait pas eu de blessés et
que sa part des rapides dans des
circonstances très bien sébastien bien
sûre on vous reparle on vous reparle je
veux
parlez à marcel savard et remettent s'il
vous plaît des images en direct je veux
qu'ils nous expliquent ce que je tente
d'expliquer mais moi je peux policiers
marcel re bonjour à vous
bonjour je pense qu'il faut souligner
pour les gens le côté là mais et
méthodique de la sphère layar pas de
monter en puissance où on va charger
c'est vraiment coin par quoi on a
subdivisé la zone à une dizaine de sous
zones convoya les 2/3 demain après
demain vous me l'aviez d'hier ça va être
longue
tout à fait les gens sont surpris parce
qu'on s'attendait avec la déclaration du
chef intérimaire belle il avait dit qu
on ne passera pas une fin de semaine
similaire mais il n'avait pas dit que le
tout serait réglé donc ce qui est
important de comprendre ce qu'on les
laisse une situation s'installer
bon plus ou moins volontairement et il
serait très malhabile d'abord des
policiers tout d'un coup de commencer à
faire des techniques de dispersion très
active très active donc ça pourrait être
des charges sur la foule
l'utilisation des irritants chimiques et
d'autres techniques que je vais faire
mais quand même ce serait très
surprenant parce que comment on peut
expliquer de max en branle donc ce qu'on
voit là c'est vraiment une stratégie de
l'établissement de leur très progressive
très méthodique que très patiente
repprelci qui aussi avec moi marcel on
va aller voir parce qu'elle rabita parce
que c'est sa caméra qui a si justement
nc de ces opérations où on est pascal en
train d'arrêter des gens
oui absolument il ya une barricade très
imposante à l'intersection des rues
rideau et colonel by et
lentement mais sûrement les policiers
mettent en état d'arrestation les
manifestants qui refusent d'obtempérer
aux ordres de quitter des lieux voyez il
ya deux policiers lourdement armés qui
sont en bas qui marchent en duo ben ce
sont les policiers de la gendarmerie
royale du canada c'est le groupe
d'intervention plus précisément il y en
a un autre troisième qui suit derrière
derrière ses collègues avec une arme
semi automatique
les policiers ont attendu toute la
premier dit patrice pour
pour tenter de voir si les gens allaient
pas partir de bonne foi mais visiblement
ils ont fait et ils ont eu plusieurs
slogans des drapeaux canadiens qui ont
flotté au dessus de leur tête on les a
nargué et là on arrive en fin d'après
midi et on sent que la stratégie
policière va passer un volet plus actifs
que passifs ce que vous voyez en bon ce
sont des gens qui ont été arrêtés par
les policiers c'est la gendarmerie
royale du canada qui s'occupe des
arrestations leur lise leurs droits
l'avons leur parler également de des
accusations éventuellement qui seront
déposées contre eux mais ce sont tous
des gens qui ont refusé de quitter les
lieux malgré les nombreux avertissements
qui ont été faits par la police d'ottawa
depuis déjà deux jours
merci beaucoup vous restez avec nous a
évidemment pascal tout au long de cette
émission qui va se poursuivre jusqu'à 18
heures marcel donc on le voit
lentement mais sûrement les ya soixante
dix personnes arrêtées le qu'on va
monter beaucoup plus que ça on ne dit
pas combien il ya de policiers mais pour
vous donner une idée
marcel si imposant il ya sept corps de
police il ya beaucoup de policiers sur
le terrain n
a pas réussi sur le terrain et des
policiers qui sont disponibles pour
prendre des relèves parce que vous savez
on quittera pas au courant de la nuit là
on va avoir des policiers qui vont
demeurer sur les lieux qu'ils vont
garder le terrain acquis dans le fond et
qui vont s'assurer que aussi la
stratégie bois poids ça continue et soit
cette nuit ou à la limite demain matin
dès que le soleil va se pointent donc le
nombre je vous dirais facilement est
encore là je peux être en dessous du
nombre qui est présent mais facilement
je prévois l'ensemble des policiers ou
au dessus de 1000 policiers qui sont
prêts à être opérationnel dans le
secteur au dessus de 1000 policiers je
rappelle aux gens que de l'autre côté il
ya environ on disait toujours à peu près
500 manifestants ce qu'il y en a un peu
moins un peu plus avec un certain nombre
de camions qui bloque toujours donc ça
vous paraît une bonne proportion là
c'est une bonne proportion dans la
stratégie qu'on veut utiliser vous savez
monsieur on veut une stratégie qui ne
recherchera pas la confrontation mais on
veut une stratégie qui va être une
stratégie de reconquérir intérêts qui a
été abandonné aux manifestants et aux
irréductibles
donc pour faire ça compte tenu de vous
l'avez bien décrire compte tenu de tous
les secteurs qui sont dans le périmètre
principal donc les sous secteurs chaque
sous secteurs qu'on va réussir à
reconquérir à stabiliser dans un état
normal mais on veut s'assurer qu'ils
rapport nouvelle petite manifestation
mais voilà on va devoir reprendre tout
ce jeu vous avec la pas ce que je vais
leur expliquer ça
il ya une dizaine de suzuka dans la dans
la zone principale une fois qu'on a
pacifié ou
arrêtés ou chasser les manifestants
d'une seconde on la boucle il ya des
clôtures et tout ça et plus personne qui
rentre là
non il ya plus personne qui rentre là
tant que
l'ensemble des secteurs ne seront pas
sécurisé ramener à leur situation et
leur état normal et tranquillement on va
reprendre une vie normale avec la
circulation et c'est dans ce cadre là
qu'on va voir une diminution des
effectifs on va voir des policiers on va
quand même regarder certaines barrières
contrainte présent que ce soit ce qu'on
appelle des doors et en ciment ou des
barrières de métal mais on va voir ça
encore pendant un bout de temps pour
faciliter la tâche mais la
démobilisation policière avant de
prendre certains jours des policiers qui
sont arrivés là que ce soit les membres
la sûreté du québec parce que c'est
quand même su réel de voir les gens à
ottawa mais les gens vont se reposer
d'un secteur dont coucher d'un secteur
y'a pas personnes qui retournent à la
maison ce soir pendant les prochaines
prochains jours les faits mentionnés
parce que on n'est pas arrivé au fait
plus combative c'est ce qu'on m'a dit de
source policière c'est que
on serait rendu à la deuxième sous
sections lorient 6 en une dizaine ça
peut donner une idée aux gens de combien
de temps ça va prendre pour aller au
boulot on veut pas parce qu'un autre
pays où d'autres un autre mentalité on
aurait pu faire ça bien différemment
tout à fait on pourrait carrément faire
de la dispersion de foules et faire de
la dispersion de foule ce sont des
méthodes et des techniques les
politiques sont présents sur les lieux
ici à tahoua connaissent utilise à
l'occasion mais on n'est pas dans ce
mode là est actuellement de voir la
dispersion avec des irritants chimie et
on l'a vu dans certains grands
événements le sommet des amériques et
aux pourparlers celui là c'est assez
évident mais on n'est pas dans ce mois
deux actuellement on est dans un mode où
on veut juste tout simplement donner le
choix aux gens et je le rappelle comment
expliquer qu'on ne tolérer une situation
pendant vrai quelques jours et du jour
au lendemain dans l'état de droit ou
somme qu'on met en branle une dispersion
énergie très ferme de fall s'est pas
explicable que ce soit juridiquement ou
socialement par là où les policiers ne
sont très conscients de ça moi je pense
qu'avec ce que je vois je suis je suis
très heureux de voir la progression
évidemment certains produits mais ça
pourrait aller plus vite il ya une
vitesse que je trouve normal
vous connaissez vous êtes une vitesse
décrire ce que vous voyez les images un
marcel
faut que je me tourne je me tourne un
petit peu de gelée ou parce qu'on vous
voit pas toutes façons ça c'est des
applications à direct qu'on voit là
et donc on voit que les policiers et
c'était à prévoir ce cas on le fait les
premières avancées au cours de l'avant
midi sur l'heure du midi c'était normal
le secteur était un peu plus facile on
un secteur difficile beaucoup de camions
des gens des barrières à travers tout ça
donc de faire une ligne de front avec
des policiers c'est un peu plus complexe
parce qu'on veut que la ligne se suivent
et qu'elle soit une ligne droite donc ce
qu'on fait c'est quand on dans ce petit
secteur là il ya des petites avancées
qui vont se faire dans des
allers-retours - sous vidéo on est au
coin on voit on est au coin de rideau ne
va pas très loin du centre des
conférences donc on est on est pas
encore arrivée devant le parlement
non on n'est pas devant le parlement
mais si c'est un point névralgique qui
une fois qui va être vraiment ramener à
une situation normale il va avoir quand
même une avance est beaucoup plus facile
par la suite parce qu'ils y ont un
espace assez long et large pour
permettre aux policiers d'avancer dans
une ligne de front unique droite qui
vont permettre d'avancer assez
rapidement mais celui-là actuellement
c'est vraiment un point névralgique et
les policiers vont prendre leur temps
mais on va voir des choses se passaient
et d'ailleurs on a vu qu'il ya eu
absolument rien qui a évolué pendant
quelques heures est déjà là on voit les
policiers ont avancé un peu on a fait
des arrestations on va avancer encore et
quand je regarde la masse de policiers
disponibles parce que l'image d'une
image plus grande on a vu ça un petit
peu plus plus tôt il avait presque à ce
moment là il y avait presque plus de
policiers plus de policiers que de
manifestants
là on ne voit pas d'enfants dans ce coin
là le chef de police stic baird a dit en
conférence de presse qu'il était
abasourdi encore quand ils y pensent de
penser que des manifestants tenet amener
leurs enfants là et il s'en servait un
peu comme comme méthode dissuasive leur
face à la france policière et vous en
pensez quoi il faut faut qu'il fasse
attention donc
ils sont ils sont les policiers les
autorités sont vraiment conscients de ça
ils sont en observation continue et je
vous dirais que il y aurait des
mouvements individuels des actions
individuelles de personnes qui se
présenteraient avec des enfants que
j'aurais l'impression tendance à dire
que on va rapidement
isolé ces personnes là on permettra pas
il y aura probablement porte d'action
directe parce qu'on veut pas on veut pas
appliquer les enfants mais est-ce qu'on
va les isoler
par rapport au reste du groupe pour ne
pas se retrouver avec un groupe
plus agressif mais les as des enfants
donc on va isoler les quelques enfants
et après ça on va travailler sur la
baisse du groupe paraît moins dix jeux
wii excusez moi écouter le joyel et
chevaux et ça il ya beaucoup de gens
j'ai reçu beaucoup de courriels sur les
chevaux ce matin les gens disaient parce
que on disait la police a choisi une
méthode vraiment presque myopathies
classé pas à pas de petits partis
les chevaux sont là pourquoi dans ma
peau pour charger mais son la peau est
ce une mesure dissuasive
cc oui c'est entre autres dissuasive
jamais raison c'est une mesure
dissuasive
c'est impressionnant ce sont des bêtes
qui sont pour ce connaisseur quasiment
débattre de 17 mètres de haut et ce sont
des bêtes heureusement 1200 livres etc
lui donc c'est dissuasif mais souvent on
va se servir des chauvauds pour
fractionner la folie parce que ça
devient extrêmement difficile
si c'est une foule compacte très très
proches les uns des autres
avec une ligne de front on a deux choix
pour fractionner une foule on va
évidemment utiliser les héritages
chimiques mais les irritants chimiques y
aura vraiment des impacts et les
citoyens autour les maisons et arrêté
plusieurs personnes au sommet des
amériques pourrait certainement vous
parler de cet aspect là ok vous les
étudiants permet de fractionner vous
avez dit tout à l'heure mais je veux que
vous le répétez pas ce que je pense
c'est une des informations les plus les
plus intéressantes à comprendre sur ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui parler du
sommet des amériques les gens sont
habitués de vue ces images j'ai été dans
plusieurs g7 mois de ses 8 il ya eu de
grosses manifestations ou rapidement
c'était soit les canons à eau soit les
gars soit on ne veut pas procéder de la
sorte dans les prochains jours c'est
clair
mais les agissements de la foule sont
aussi différents rappelons-nous les
agissements de la foule qu'elle se soit
prononcée ce qui reste d'un livre de la
mémoire collective le sommet des
amériques
il y avait des projectiles qui était
lancée on tentait de même on a même
réussi à mettre la culture à terre on
voulait se rendre carrément dans le parc
dans le centre des congrès pour
perturber la rencontre des dirigeants et
là il y avait vraiment une foule qui
devaient être dispersés pour permettre
justement un contrôle plus facile et
c'est là qu'on a vu les hitachi
actuellement ce qu'on voit c'est une
foule qui ne veut pas quitter et ce
n'est pas une foule à ce stade-ci qui
qui est prête à affronter les policiers
en lançant des projectiles en
s'attaquant à eux en boule à entrer dans
des complexes particulier si c'était
exemple on voyait des gens gloire
entrées dans le parlement
là on est dans un autre état on est
vraiment ailleurs mais c'est pour ça
qu'on voit aujourd'hui n'ont d'ailleurs
on va pour des générations qui est là
qui l'autre côté un l'image qu'on voit
ce sont 15 man j'ai du côté des
manifestants
sébastien vous vous sentez la police qui
vient vers vous là
en ce moment les policiers tiennent la
ligne ce que vous voyez par contre à
droite c'est
un amas de manifestants un groupe de
manifestants qui semble pousser contre
les policiers un peu comme on l'a vu ce
matin ya là-dedans plusieurs corps de
police qui tiennent la lune parce que
derrière qu'est ce qu'il ya il ya les
camions qui sont stationnés qui occupe
le que l'intersection rideau mackenzie à
ottawa patrice vous connaissez votre
tahoua c'est tout juste à côté du
château laurier on à château le riz dans
notre dos et là les policiers ils
avancent tranquillement vers nous ceux
qui sont un peu plus à gauche baiia des
gens disent qu'ils adorent mais le gros
de je vous dirais 2
le gros de l'altercation
manifestants contre policiers ça se
passe un peu à notre droite vous voyez
probablement des têtes qui bouge des
vagues entre les manifestants et les
policiers ça c'est parce que ça pousse
et puis ici on voit son 3e enfant leur
ligne c'est trop de profond du policier
les manifestants
il ya des endroits où ils sont huit à
dix de profonds on vous laisse entendre
plus que ça donne à faire
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais manifestants patrice qui crie shame
shame honte honte à vous et là on vient
de voir on vient de voir un mode de
neige peut-être un peu de glace qui a
été lancée ça c'est pas de bonne idée
parce qu'à partir du moment où les
policiers ça votre invité patrice poil
confirmé à partir du moment où il ya des
tirs et des bottes de paille et tire
vraiment mais les choses sous policiers
ça représente des projectiles et voilà
ça ça peu présente une escalade que les
policiers même pas du tout ils ne
toléreront pas on imagine
qu'elle loue également
sous commissaire à la gendarmerie à la
retraite bien sûr royale du canada
monsieur bourdiaux âgées pas si vous
m'entendez j'ai trouvé que marcel savard
et notre collègue qui est avec le
manifesto monsieur bordurage en profite
d'abord pour vous saluer
comment vous comment vous pouvez nous
expliquer à votre façon ce qui est en
train de se passer là on accélère leur
est d'aider des arrestations veut ce
petit groupe devant château laurier l'on
veut on veut qu'ils se dispersent là
exactement comme marcel l'indiqué c'est
que on a pris une pause pour offrir la
possibilité aux gens après plusieurs
avertissements de quitter les lieux il
est évident que les gens les plus pures
les plus durs ont choisi de demeurer sur
place après cette pause d'environ deux
heures l'homme est un des policiers
rentrent en action pour pouvoir avancer
vers la colline parlementaire donc est
certain que s'envoient des messages
clairs que si vous choisissez de
demeurer là il va avoir des conséquences
est ce que c'est ce que les policiers
sont encore présentes la force du nombre
d
de la force policière elle est là on a
parlé avec marcel plus tôt on ne sait
pas exactement combien ils sont mais au
moins 1000 comme disait marcel c'est par
elle pour ce genre d'opération plus
patiente disons ça prend beaucoup de
monde ça prend beaucoup de monde puisse
et c'est quand même parce que il faut
comprendre que là là là sports ce que
les policiers exercent reçoit une force
égale du côté des mêmes gestes donc on
essaie de garder ce juste équilibre là
pour bien doser les choses mais les gens
ont leurs marques certaines personnes
qui sont arrêtés ils sont immédiatement
envoyés dans la ligne derrière la ligne
secondaire et c'est à partir de ce point
là que les policiers maîtrisent
d'individus et a même un duvet l'aria
pour être acheminés vers le panier à
salade est en jeu dans ce contexte la
wii les i non je le dirai êtes vous vous
aussi
impressionné en tout cas vous remarqué
que le choix qui a été fait c'est d'y
aller le plus mollo possible le plus
doucement passé mais fermement mais sa
charge est donc une façon sûre les
manifestants c'est un choix que vous
trouvé judicieux
dans les circonstances oui mais ce qu'il
faut penser aussi c'est que c'est un
milieu urbain donc il est important de
s'assurer de pouvoir bien contenir les
manifestants mais aussi en même temps
vous voyez y ont avancé rapidement ya eu
il ya eu des manifestants qui se sont
rués qu'on dépense il ya eu contact
physique il ya eu de mouvement qui
allait d'un côté comme de l'autre et le
voyez vous les policiers ont arrêté au
mieux gérer ce qu'ils viennent de les
personnes qui viennent d'arrêter on
prend une pause ça donne l'occasion aux
gens de reculer et loeb un psy est
évident que les policiers vont réengagé
avec les manifestants au cours des
débats possiblement des prochaines
minutes les policiers se sont invectivés
mais ça ça fait partie du
contexte mais les policiers demeurent
quand même en façon stratégique est très
bien déployer gardent leur calme
et repoussent les gens l'oeil est
certain que on leur a offert un choix
des gens ont choisi de demeurer là et là
les policiers envoyé un message clair
que on progresse on avance vers le but
ultime qui évidemment le devant du
parlement où est ce que le gros des
manifestants sont encore bons un mousse
on a tellement parlé sur sur les camions
là on se concentre sur les individus sur
les arrestations ou ceux qui partent en
mieux ce qui reste on l'est on va les
arrêter les camions ce serait une autre
étape fall et sécuriser les camions
avant de les prendre j'imagine qu'on les
observe monsieur abords du 1o dans fait
cesser yoyo on va s'occuper des des gens
puis lorsque les policiers si vous avez
remarqué un peu plus tôt et policiers
lorsqu'ils ont encerclé un de ses
camions là ils sont empressés de pouillé
ce camion là pour s'assurer numéro que
pour quelqu'un qui est à l'intérieur du
camion parce que le camion peut devenir
rapidement une arme en soit contre les
policiers qui s'approchent de ceux de ce
véhicule la deuxième main pour voir si
justement porte des explosifs ou des
armes à l'intérieur de ce camion là et
par la suite les policiers une fois que
le camion contrôle et on poursuit la la
la route en s'assurant de sécuriser ce
véhicule marcel pierre et vous restez
vous permettez je rappelle marcel bieri
vous fait des heures et des heures
kompass vous restez avec nous à 5h les
gens de la première chaîne vont se
joindre à nous je veux qu'on reste sur
ces images là sébastien est ce que vous
vous attendez encore sébastien vous
entends toujours pas traîné l'impression
que
est-ce qu'on peut atteindre un plus haut
à octon une seule
[Musique]
gm je me paye aujourd'hui j'ai
envoyé patrice la ligne avance on est
devant nous une section de la ligne qui
composée d'agents de la sûreté du québec
plus adroite de nous mais vous avez des
agents de la région de york c'est en
banlieue de toronto c'est aussi des
agents de service de police d'ottawa
mais la section qui devant nous ce sont
des agents de la saq qui l'a à leur tour
pour tenir la ligne ont repoussé les
gens je vous dirais que
comparé à ce qu'on avait à windsor
patrice et je reviens là dessus parce
qu'on n'y a été vraiment plusieurs jours
c'est une
une opération qui est beaucoup plus
complexe parce que windsor ce que vous
aviez c'est un grand boulevard qui
donnait sur le pont ambassador avec
quelques rues transversales
perpendiculaire qu'il fallait garder il
n'y avait pas autant d'interceptions
puis avait pas autant de difficultés à
maintenir une ligne pour les policiers
lorsqu'il avance et il va certainement
pas aussi autant de manifestants qui
s'opposait au travail que les policiers
font hélas vous voyez ce travail là des
policiers vous voyez nos positions des
manifestants il ya encore énormément de
de résistance de la part des manières si
merci je vous reparle dans quelques
secondes mesdames et messieurs on va
accueillir les gens de la première
chaîne
[Musique]
inquiet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
moi
mesdames et messieurs bonne fin d'après
midi si patrice roy et toute l'équipe de
radio canada sur le terrain à tahoua
poursuivre cette grande opération
policière qui regroupe sept corps
policiers dirigés par la police d'ottawa
jusqu'ici depuis ce matin 70
arrestations
également certains un certain nombre de
véhicules qui ont déjà quittés mais vous
le voyez ça c'est des images en direct
il y a actuellement un face à face entre
les forces policières et un noyau quand
même assez important de manifestants qui
ne veut pas quitter les lieux encore
beaucoup de camions sur la rue
wellington c'est ce que vous voyez
actuellement ça sera peut-être la
dernière étape de cette opération qui
s'annonce longue on a décidé de jouer de
patience d'y aller pouce par pouce
littéralement on a si on peut voir la
carte de la zone rouge la zone occupée
de tahoua on a subdivisé cette carte en
10 secondes ou en rouge une dizaine en
tout cas et étape par étape souvent par
seconde on va soir étaient les gens
soient leur demander de partir et depuis
ce matin c'est exactement ce qu'on fait
on est rendu à peu près à la deuxième
seconde sur une dizaine ça vous donne
une idée mesdames et messieurs de la
longueur de cette opération policière
importante qui est loin loin d'être
terminée ça va prendre encore plusieurs
heures sinon quelques jours sur le
terrain sébastien c'est françois que
l'on retrouve pascal robidas et lise
allard louis blouin également il ya
toute une dimension politique à cette
crise ailleurs le parlement de t'avoir
été fermée aujourd'hui compte tenu de
l'opération policière on voulait pas
comme on dit aux gens de partir on
voulait pas en plus devoir assurer la
sécurité des députés sébastien
saint-françois je commence avec vous
c'est vos images qu'on voit c'est devant
le château laurier un jet de pierre du
parlement où là il ya une confrontation
police manifestants
oui votre est ce une confrontation qui
dure depuis maintenant plusieurs minutes
vous voyez probablement un amas de gens
assez mélangé mais là dedans il ya des
manifestants qui bras dessus bras
dessous font une chaîne humaine devant
les policiers qui tiennent eux leurs
lignes les policiers ce qu'ils essaient
de faire pour les gens qui nous écoutent
qui joignent à nous pauli essaient de
regagner du terrain sur la rue rideau
qui se transforme en montant derrière
nous henri wallon
du parlement on est d'environ l'a pas
comme ceux débloqués moins de 5 de marge
pour se rendre au parlement donc mais
pas ici ils ont regagné déjà le
l'intersection précédente c'est à dire
mais kenzy reed où il ya énormément de
camions qui sont toujours stationnés ils
ont entre guillemets nettoyer cette
intersection là on fait plusieurs
arrestations certains camionneurs qui ne
voulait pas quitter et là ils sortent de
l'intersection sorte de cet amas de ce
qu a man who on peut le dire comme ça
deux semi remorques pour tranquillement
gagné du terrain ce rideau le problème
qu'ils ont en ce moment pas triste c'est
que il ya une très grosse opposition des
manifestants les gens regardent et
perdit entre autres est aussi la
première chaîne a plus aujourd'hui avait
probablement des confrontations entre
les policiers et des manifestants
il y avait à ce moment là probablement
une centaine de manifestants en ce
moment on est à plusieurs centaines de
manifestants ils sont trois quatre cinq
de large de profonds contre les
policiers qui pousse
il ya des arrestations mais il ya
surtout une confrontation à certains
moments qui est au corps à corps et je
voyais probablement un peu dans
l'arrière-salle
les chenilles chevaux ouais ça c'est
pour ce que j'en vois grâce aux ex on
sait les agents cheval de la police de
toronto qui sont ici c'est assez
impressionnant lorsqu'il s'avance là il
se retire mais ils ont été avancés tout
juste derrière la première ligne devrait
peut-être y avoir un message là dedans
mais pour l'instant il se retire donc
c'est là où on en est patrice les
présente même si cette heure presque
17h04 et les policiers ils ont commencé
ses opérations lors aux environs de 8
heures ce matin ils ont fait à vue ni
lot deux campements de
un camionneur qui semble avoir dégagé
évidemment il faudra que des panneaux
espace pour enlever ces véhicules là
mais deux campements de kamenar qui
semble avoir dégagé ils ont probablement
fait environ un kilomètre la partie du
premier jusqu'à ici et là ils
s'attaquent de certaines manières
exclusivement l'expression à la rue
rideau qui se transporte à wellington
voilà s'attaque au noyau dur à faire au
regroupement le plus important de
personnes
je vise plus permettre patricia neal et
moi peut-être de vous interrompre ou à
peu près 6 à 700 mètres derrière nous
veut pas le voir en ce moment mais sur
la rue wellington en face du parlement
est en ce moment en fait
c'est un
dijon juxtaposition qui presque surréel
il ya des gens qui sont devant moi en
train de se
proposer aux policiers physiquement il
ya des gens qui pleurent il ya des gens
qui poussent il y en a qui sortent y en
a qui reviennent mais c'est sa 100
mètres derrière moi il ya une fête
devant le parlement de purs et durs qui
veulent continuer les policiers sont pas
encore rendus là mais
on sent que ça pourrait s'y rendre à
quelque part ça c'est bien je rappel
merci on vous convient vous revoir je
suis marseillais savent bourdieu savard
ancien directeur j'ai rejoint de la
sûreté du québec pierre bourdieu at
sous-commissaire comment vous pouviez en
quelques mots qualifié expliquer aux
téléspectateurs le type d'opération que
l'on que l'on voit actuellement
monsieur ça va pour moi si vous me
permettez selon me permettez c'est
vraiment une opération qui est
minutieuse qui est chirurgical on prend
les tables de faire les choses il ya
beaucoup de stratégique qui se passe en
même temps sébastien votre journaliste a
bien mentionné quand on a vu les chevaux
s'avancer ce que ça permet c'est que ça
permet un espèce de petit espace minimes
la foule regarde ça s'en tenir là une
réaction vers l'arrière et voici
l'espace qui n'était pas actuellement
gagner entre les policiers les toasts
policiers et les citoyens donc et toutes
des petites stratégies comme ça qui sont
payantes et qui sont vraiment je vous
dirais de haut niveau long on est
vraiment au niveau de l'intervention
policière par ce qui me concerne est
méthodique la wii précise vous dit et il
faut remarquer avant de vous écouter
pierre yves bondu à que la police a fait
un point de presse d'ottawa il n'y a eu
aucun blessé
rapportés chez les manifestants
0-1 blessés du côté des forces
policières mais les jets ont dit a été
et
coupé à la main mais pas grave gravement
donc tous bords du rhin ça montre que
jusqu'ici ça marche bien
tous ont bien fonctionné mais une image
qui m'a vraiment frappé au cours des
dernières 15 minutes c'est que les
policiers étaient stables est arrêté
dans une ligne puis évidemment était sur
le point d'avancé et il y avait une dame
qui était le
savons ce que c'est moi que je regardais
chevaux
là on a décidé d'y aller pour la
dispersion là on fractionne si vous me
permettez
de fractionner la foule c'est exactement
ce que je vous disais pas trop regarder
l'effet que ça leur sur la folle on
fractionne la foule un petit groupe et
par la suite voyez-vous les policiers
vont reprendre du terrain
alors c'est exact
les cavaliers ils ont probablement eu un
ordre on le suppose mais un coupé en
deux
à la jonction entre les manifestants et
les policiers ils ont fait reculer les
manifestants d'à peu près 30 à 40 mètres
au presque d'un coup il y avait des
poches je vous dirais de résidence plus
agressive au centre de la ligne d'essai
poche là avaient l'air de donner du fil
à retordre vraiment voit ici depuis
plusieurs minutes on peut présumer sans
trop de risque de se tromper que
quelqu'un dit bon là on a besoin d'un
peu plus d espace et en passant les
chevaux deux de large entre la ligne des
policiers et la ligne des manifestants
voilà vous avez eu un mouvement de foule
comme vous l'aviez décrit comme notre
invité la dcri aussi un peu plus tôt
c'est râpé il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont été très surpris nous on les a vus
arriver deux côtés on savait ce qui se
passait mais peu de gens avaient prévu
qu'il arriverait comme ça des cavaliers
et qu'il repousserait d'un coup tous les
to les manifestants oui bien il sait se
fera pas on a d'abord retiré les chevaux
baye sont arrivées quand même assez
rapidement et en allant vers la foule
pour la séparer en deux
oui c'est que l'effet surprise était
quand même là les puits ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les chevaux ont
été vus depuis à peu près de tout début
de la manifestation et marcel avez
absolument raison quand tu parlais du
d'utilisation de 2,6 c bay qui sont
quand même impressionnant pour justement
ouvrir ouvrir les disperser la foule
l'alliance que je lui ai mentionné ou du
véhicule derrière
c'est pas vaincu là où on n'a pas ça
il ya comme un non ça c'est un haut
parleur on va leur parler là
rien au bâlois puis aussi normalement il
mieux policiers qui se trouvent ou déçu
de ce véhicule là pour observer les
mouvements foule aussi n'a donc tenu
d'une stratégie ici et pas seulement une
stratégie de déploiement tactique il ya
aussi le frij au niveau de l' influence
du déploiement policier sur la pensée de
la foule réaction de la foule vis-à-vis
ce déploiement le don qui est certain
que dans ce contexte l'or la présence de
ce véhicule nord des chevaux permet de
justement influencer la perception
d'acool en ce qui a trait au déploiement
policier parce que on arrivait à un
point où est ce qu il y avait un
mouvement foule qui push qui semblait
vouloir repousser les policiers vers du
terrain gagné donc est important ce
moment-là de s'assurer d'une
intervention comme par exemple les
chevaux pour justement s'assurer que une
fragmentation de la foule pour que les
policiers puissent regagner encore plus
au terrain et on a vu un para que vous
parliez des arrestations qui continue à
se faire donc on est de l'autre de
l'autre côté où on voit le camion avant
plat on va remontrer
la séquence des chevaux là qu'on a eu en
direct parce que c'est
oui on disait que on est patient on est
mais quand même là on a voulu marquer en
dix ans l on peut pas garder ce groupe
il ya trop de monde non le voile
exigeant et il c'est évident et voilà et
c'était évident que c'était le but 2-2
si vous remarquez les chevaux se
positionne entre la foule et les
policiers immédiatement après que les
chevaux passent les policiers gang le
terrain et repousse les manifestants
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est de
remarque à quel point la situation est
volatile à quel point des manifestants
qui sont là semble déterminé et il ya
une image qui m'a frappé un peu plus tôt
avant l'intervention c'était que y avait
il y avait quand même
une personne qui était là qui y change
qui corps humain un enfant près d'elle
puis qui disait entre autres que l avait
là elle était désespérée puis elle
gardait son sa position pour permettre
que nos arguments aucune avance n'est
pas
le leur le chef de la police d'ottawa
dit encore encore en direct là ils
reviennent ils veulent vraiment scindé
et on est devant château laurier ceux
qui connaissent ottawa et là les
policiers chargent derrière
parce qu ils peuvent pas attendre
éternellement il faut ce sont des choses
exactement époux qui a écouté quand tu
perds et puisqu'il faut que furtivement
par loin il avance fait sur les nouveaux
lecteurs en direct ouest vers le
parlement donc on veut le faire de façon
pacifique p ar certains prêts les
policiers ou avait avancé pour francky
terrain et c'est dans ce contexte que
les chevaux sont évidemment utiliser
ya cette compagnie sied impliqués dans
cette opération
la police d'ottawa la police de toronto
la sûreté du québec la police
provinciale ontarienne la police de new
york entre autres banques bref comment
est-ce que c'est quel est le défi à
votre avis messieurs de la coordination
pas ça sert bien coordonnées on laisse
le on laisse la direction à la police
d'ottawa puis chacun connaît son rôle
coin marcel
d'abord je seule utilisation de la
cavalerie déjà là c'est signe qu'il ya
une telle une communication entre les
organisations qui est importante on peut
pas surprendre les membres la sûreté du
québec que ce soit ou le pipi avec un
mouvement de cavale alors que les autres
sont qu'un courant que ça s'en vient
donc il ya vraiment une belle
communication
un système qui ne fonctionne et
rappelons nous fera sonner si ce sont
des systèmes qui ne se parlent le port
donc tout se passe par un centre de
commandement qui réécrit real et les
différents points 6 capotier partir ok
un mouvement de la cavalerie et faites
attention soyez prudent soyez alerte et
gagner le territoire il ya toute une
coordination à communication qui se paie
cash trouve excellente jusqu'à
maintenant je suis très impressionné ce
n'est pas si les gens c'est pas si
compliqué les avants c'est une opération
extrêmement complexe avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments qui arrive qu'il
faut gérer
oui ce qui est intéressant c'est que je
vois médecin est également les policiers
sont sur le
le château laurier à l'entrée du château
laurier dans l'ère de la libye et
poursuit justement de se faire dépasser
par des médecins dont qu'ils essaient de
pile - dans la mesure du possible de
garder des gens alors dans une
section donné pourquoi vieux les comptes
publics et éviter tout dépassement si
bogarde à l'arrière il ya une deuxième
une troisième ligne de policiers pour
justement éviter de 6,1 où des
manifestants passent la ligne de fond
qui sont dans l'oeil d'autres politiques
sont par la suite puis prête à
intercepter si le débordement d'un côté
comme de l'autre
marcel est bien rives si on était à
paris ou si on était à londres son était
même aux états unis à chicago et une
situation comme celle là se produisait
depuis longtemps à paris entre quoi les
crs va arriver un pays aurait foncé dans
le tome ya une manière de faire qui est
propre à notre société ici pierrine
absolument
pour moi ça reflète un peu le type de
société qu'on dit on est des gens qui
recherchent
ultime en parle à une résolution
pacifique et là on est en face d'une
situation où les gens sont très émotifs
pour eux il ya des gens là dedans qui
ont perdu leur emploi et l'émotivité
fait surface les policiers qui sont des
professionnels sont très au fait tu au
niveau des motifs dé comprennent sommet
ont un travail après ce qui s est passé
de la peur dans le respect de l'individu
mais il reste quand même tuyau y ont vu
un travail à part à des situations sont
hautement difficile hautement émotif
pour pour ces gens là qui pour eux c'est
c'est presque leur dernier repos leur
dernier bastion où essaie de se faire
entendre de se faire comprendre et aussi
ce qui pour réaliser c'est que pau la
plupart de ces gens là il s'agit encore
dans leur esprit d'une manifestation
légale puisque selon eux le ch l'achat
des droits canadienne leur permet de
manifester paisiblement
je ne joue le demande à vous de avant
d'aller voir mon collègue louis blouin
parce que du tout neuf il ya un
arrière-plan politique important c'est
la première fois depuis
1988 qu'on fait usage de cette loi sur
les mesures d'urgence et le cadre légal
l'ontario avait évoqué avaient instauré
l'état d'urgence ottawa également est-ce
que ce que vous voyez ce qu'on voit pas
parce qu'il ya eu des comptes
paralysé il ya eu des des saisies de
véhicules ce que vous voyez est ce que
ça aurait pu avoir lieu pareil sans ce
cadre d'exception marcel et pierre-yves
ensuite bas et crée d'abord rappelons
nous que la ville d'ottawa a déjà fait
sa déclaration d'urgence donc on était
quand même dans un contexte similaire en
les pouvoirs sont sensiblement les mêmes
à un niveau différent au niveau
juridique et la province d'ontario de
l'avait fait aussi donc déjà là on a un
palier supérieur maintenant ce que ça
permet c'est aussi de dire que nous
prenons l'autre côté de la rivière ça
permet aussi au québec de dire ben nous
là on peut aussi empêcher les gens de
contribuer d'approvisionner et autres en
se servant des éléments de cet état
d'urgence donc pour moi c'est un plus
c'était bénéfique et de dire que si on
n'a pas besoin de ça moi je ne suis pas
là pour faire de la politique
d'une perspective de points s'ils se sa
stratégie policière moi je pense que
c'est facilitant de la voir ça permet
vraiment de faire des stratégies et des
opérations tactiques qui vont et ciblées
qui vont avoir un assise juridique
solide et c'est ça l'important pour les
familles via les autorités que d'avoir
une assise une annexe et on va les jouer
donna parole d'une seconde monsieur père
yves après on va l'écouter sur le
terrain
alors c'est le cris liberté liberté le
freedom alors qu'ils arrivent pour vous
où vous en êtes d'adam dans votre
estimation de la nécessité ou pas de ce
cadre de la loi d'urgence
de deux volets pour moi ce qui est
important c'est que premièrement on va
où l'argent et si vous frappez dans le
portefeuille de ces gens là au niveau
des saisies des confiscations de
déblocage des comptes de banque et que
en même temps vous avertis c'est que des
conséquences sérieuses avec
l'utilisation ou la révocation de votre
permis de conduire votre permis
d'opération et vos assurances il ya des
conséquences sérieuses pour les gens qui
choisissent de demeurer en place le
deuxième volet c'est qu'au niveau du
support logistique pour les policiers
avant que la loi d'urgence au niveau
fédéral soit invoquée il ya tous les
roms les compagnies de remorquage dans
la grande région d'ottawa refusé de s'
investir ou de participer à ce que les
véhicules qui occupent autour de la
colline soit déplacé mais avec 7 ou
alors ils sont forcés de s'impliquer et
jusqu'à maintenant on a environ on va
leur en marquage et en attendant qu'on
voit derrière les chevaux qui reviennent
donc soyez attentif mais ce que j'allais
me décrire peut-être qu'ils reviennent
simplement se placer comme il était
avant en arrière plan pour laisser
savoir qu'ils sont pas très loin c'est
impressionnant marcel vous le disiez
tout à l'heure un cheval là c'est
impressionnant en soi
pourraient confirmer ou pas mais les
deux mouvements de laquelle vallery
point de vue il me semble que la foule
elle est moins dense moins compact face
aux policiers il ya probablement déjà la
fin du mois oui oui j'ai rien vous tout
de suite justement sébastien qu'est ce
que ça a produit parce que forcément
vous avez un grand tante par rapport à
lyon qu'est ce que ça a produit comme ai
fait
écouter il ya certainement moins urgent
qu'il y en avait au début il a foulé les
moins compact élégant même encore très
nombreuses à certains endroits ces 3 4
de profonde devant les policiers mais il
ya moins de contacts directs entre les
manifestants qui veulent ici on sent que
les manifestants qui sont en première
ligne
se laisse une petite marge de manoeuvre
disons c'est comme ça qu'ils n'avaient
peut-être pas tantôt et qu'ils ont dû
à laquelle ils ont dit qu'ils ont dû
donner aux policiers à cause de
l'intervention des policiers à cheval
haute à des gens qui scandent encore
fluide freedom pour l'instant la ligne
est arrêté mais je vous dirais que dès
qu'on a vu des policiers sera menée
derrière les deux premières lignes les
policiers à cheval sera mis derrière les
deux premières lignes de policiers il ya
bien des gens qui ont focus est focalisé
leur attention sur ses chevaux tout le
monde veut savoir ce qui s'est passé
parce que les deux premières passes pour
10 passes d'armes mais les deux
premières passes des agents à cheval
elles ont surpris bien des gens et ça
devait pas être confortable lorsqu'on
est en première ligne
merci merci sébastien ouais parce que
c'est le mot d'ordre on le dit depuis le
début c'est du côté de la police on a
dit moins de force possible mais ça veut
pas dire pas de force du tout un pierre
yves
exactement et lb ça doit être quand même
clair que york d'une progression doit
être visible et au niveau des corps
policiers qui sont qu'en présence vous
remarqué qu'il ya un temps d'arrêt et
par la suite d'un mouvement vers la
direction ouest en direction du
parlement
l'effet dissuasif que les chevaux ont eu
eux est quand même très intéressant vous
avez mentionné un peu plus tôt aussi
marcel de l'homme de souligner c'est que
il ya aucune aucune utilisation gaz
lacrymogène on essaie dans la mesure du
possible de bien contrôler la foule par
part évidemment avoir un nombre
considérable de policiers déployés sur
le terrain mais il doit avoir des
avancées puisque il faut qu'on gagne du
terrain afin d'envoyer le message clair
aux personnes qui occupent d'ottawa
qu'il ya une date d'expiration est un
groupe ça y est c'est quoi pour vous là
je vais vous torturer la voulait mais
marcel et puis voilà le moment où ça
sera totalement libéré que la ville va
être redonnée aux résidents vous compte
tenu du rythme à une journée c'est quoi
encore demain toute la journée
facilement
si vous me permettez je consulte et ma
boule de cristal mais ceci étant dit il
reste facilement trente six heures pour
moi et reste facilement 1 36 à 48 heures
encore est ce que on peut prévoir que la
ville va être complètement ouverte cette
fin de semaine je ne crois pas qu'on
soit rendu de
cet accord bien vivre oui j'étais jeune
j'étais au cours des 3 dernières fins de
semaine au centre ville marché auto
c'était incroyable toutes les élites des
camionnettes qu'il y avait autour toutes
les installations qui avait été installé
presque en permanence dont de faire tout
ça les véhicules qu'ils poseront être
remorqué est ni plus ni moins pour la
ville d'être
nettoyé autour de tous sur le
savoir-être travaillent d'arrache-pied
je marchais les très
conservateur et bien bon on parle de
probablement plus de soixante douze 72
les plus 72 heures et plus essayer repas
en fait on le souhaite pas deux mamans
feu d'artifice long on va voir des
charges énormes on veut y aller comme ça
avec un rythme des avancées comme vous
dites parce qu'il faut pas paralysé mais
on se donne le temps d'agir de manière
la plus
la plus douce possible n'y a pas
d'autres mots pour eux merci beaucoup
vous restez là je veux parler je lui
avais parlé
est-ce que c'était le jour 4 ou 5 de
cette manifestation on est je vous le
rappelle mesdames et messieurs le jour
22 claude bonnet vous êtes commerçant
votre commerce est pas très loin de ce
qu'on décrit du tout à leur propriétaire
du moulin de provence le marché by à
ottawa monsieur bonnet bonsoir
la cavalerie t'arriver pour libérer vos
devez vous content moi j'attends que les
clés tu pourrais ouvrir vous êtes fermez
là depuis tout ce temps oui bien on a
affirmé celui qui est sûre m captée puis
on a en a gardé ce débat y voir parce
que bon il ya quand même moins
d'activité au niveau du trafic
manifestations la mais par contre bon
ben c'est vraiment rôle à 10% non mais
vous êtes vous êtes satisfait vous
regardez ça vous dit ça sera long je le
disais tout à l'heure je peux vous avez
entendu on serait à paris l'appui que ça
déjà ça a été beaucoup plus vous vous
les connaissez les crs
a rien à voir là on a méthode canadienne
+12 plus lent puis mais enfin plus
méthodique on verra mais comment vous
réagissez depuis son bureau côté
franchement faut dire que le haut tous
les gens des services de police qui sont
là je pense qu'ils sont d'une d'un
calmée et je pense que c'est l'esprit de
réaliser ça dans le calme et et je pense
que c'était bien expliquée par vos
auditeurs
et les gens qui sont du milieu policier
de l'andi heaven ou d'un règlement dans
le calme sans blessures sont le moins
possible en tout temps puis celle
cerveau fait exactement l'esprit
canadien et de la politique et de l'état
d'esprit de démocratie donc enfin
franchement bravo à tous de la police
tous les services policiers c'est du
bon monsieur bonnet donc vous que ça
prenne deux ou trois jours vous avez
tellement attendu que vous dites je sais
que la lumière au bout du tunnel pour
apprendre là une expression on
n'est plus à ça près maintenant de
limiter ce qu'il faut que ces gens ils
rentrent chez eux on retrouve un état
d'esprit qu'on remette la vie à la ville
tous les jours puis écoutez je pense
même pas moi je pense à tous les
résidents d'ottawa qui sont ils sont
malmenés les connais tous les tous les
riverains qui sont autour de la colline
là c'est absolument incroyable ces gens
là ils ont vécu le l'enfer depuis 22
jours les faut penser à salé les
premiers quinze jours 9 3 c'était
affreux le jour la nuit les parties
l'alcool en tout cas il ya 10 ans tout
le le bain tourbillon c'est inexplicable
d'ailleurs pour que notre chef de police
là il ait pu passer tout ce temps là en
délaissant la télévision tous les soirs
parce que physiquement c'est intolérable
moi j'ai apprécié son départ mais alors
heureusement que oui en quelques jours
on a vu un changement rapide avec des
gens qui ont exécutif dans l'entente des
décisions
ouais parce que dès le début vous me
disiez moi j'ai rien contre des gens
viennent ont crié leur exaspération face
aux mesures sans tain mais qu'il reparte
on les a entendu merci bonsoir
depuis le début on est tous d'accord
avec ça tout le monde a droit de
revendiquer une manifestation on
connaissait à ottawa ça à tous les to
les manifestations qui ont lieu depuis
des années sont toujours bien passé si
je n'ai jamais vu un siècle pareil et là
on est en vie dans l'apothéose alors là
on s'est plus posé mais plus d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle ils sont l'homme
moi j'ai cru de tous les gens que les
jours je me dis bien à qui l'encadrement
dit que l'économie de ces la politique
toc qui s'entendent plutôt autant qu'ils
sont entre les deux voisins c'est plus
trop les américains tout le monde est là
c'est la foire est donc complètement
sonné dans une fois dans paille ne sait
vraiment incroyable bon ben monsieur
bonnet
soulagement à bientôt pour vous et pour
tous les commerçants vous avez raison le
souligner ce n'est pas que vous tous les
commerçants de la ville de gaoua du
centre ville d'ottawa merci de nous
avoir parlé plus vous irez en pin faire
vos pâtisseries vos plats vaut
absolument
oui c'est très bien monsieur d'une
époque où mes enfants et mes veaux
croissant il ya mille ans merci a
bientot versant voir louis blouin tout
ce temps là on annoncé ce matin que le
parlement elle est fermée parce qu'on ne
voulait pas mêler les gens alors louis
c'est quand même sira foules d'iraniens
ferme parce qu'il ya un débat qui se
poursuit sur ce cadre d'urgence ouais
absolument et c'est la première fois
vous avez raison de mentionner parce que
c'est important que le processus
démocratique est interrompu au parlement
canadien depuis le début de cette
manifestation il ya trois semaines et là
patrice on a trois questions qui restent
sans réponses d'abord qu'un les députés
pourront revenir au parlement canadien
au plus tôt demain matin mais ça va
dépendre la situation parce que là on
n'ait vraiment pas rendu dans une zone
sécurisée sur la rue wellington qui est
tout juste en avant tu es ce qui
pourrait y avoir d'option pour les
parlementaires de siéger virtuellement
le problème c'est que ça prend du
personnel au parlement pour que ça
fonctionne alors laissé seul problème en
ce moment pour cette option là après ça
ce qu'on pourrait décider de repousser
que les ajouter des heures de débat sur
ces mesures d'urgence pendant la nuit
pendant la fin de semaine parce qu'il ya
des débats qui étaient prévues toute la
fin de semaine ça doit se poursuivre
lundi et l'autre question quand on va
lier le vote était prévu lundi soir sur
ses mesures d'urgence est-ce qu'on va le
repousser d'une journée est ce qu'on va
juste enlever des journées de débats
mais il ya des députés qui voulaient
s'exprimer et puis l'autre question
c'est que si les russes ont dégagé
patrice d'ici quelques jours est ce que
ça va changer la dynamique du débat
parce que là vous avez le npd qui a dit
nous on est prêt à appuyer le
gouvernement dans ces mesures mais si on
est dans le retour au calme au pas dans
la capitale fédérale est-ce qu'ils vont
dans la rue consentir qu'ils ont la
légitimité voté pour ça
arrêtons nous
là dessus c'est un point important
quelques secondes par là qu'on a vu une
image absolument extraordinaire
je presse qu on leur dirait que cette
image où on voit bien celle là parce
qu'on voit vraiment que c'est devant ce
qu'on suit depuis presque 5 40 minutes
l'affrontement entre les manifestants et
la police devant le château laurier que
vous voyez bien on voit bien les
proportions la distance le parlement
derrière alors une fois que le chanteur
lauriers ce sera réglé pour les forces
policières les gens seront dispersées ou
arrêtés remarque ça peut aller on peut
accélérer peut-être le tempo et
peut-être avoir un parlement ouvert le
10 matin et peut-être pas demain mais
lundi ou vers un endroit mais louis
revenons au npd limpide et à dia
monsieur trudeau moi je vais voter avec
vous sur ce projet de loi sur les
mesures d'urgence mais là vous si tout
est calme lundi politiquement c'est un
peu plus dur pour lui quoi que ça serait
dur de ne de trahir sa parole de ne pas
voter les libéraux non plus ouais de
faire marche arrière en quelque sorte et
surtout que les libéraux là et dire d'un
côté il faut qu'on fasse du réseau dans
le temps ce qui a des manifestants qui
pourrait revenir je vous propose
d'écouter ciblé chef adjoint du npd là
dessus alexandre boulerice et d'autres
députés conservateurs et bloquistes eux
sont opposés à ces mesures d'urgence
très bien si a plus d'occupation
illégale c'est plus de blocus s'il ya
plus d'objets pour voter pour cette loi
là le npd on pourrait considérer
voter autrement dans ces situations
l'exigent je crois pas que la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence a été l'élément
déclencheur de cette opération qu'on a
ce matin chose certaine c'est bien de
voir que les policiers font en sorte de
libérer la rue wellington s'il y avait
eu une action concertée des forces
policières avaient
avec une cause politique qui aurait pris
rapidement ses responsabilités et loge
vise particulièrement le vent damas
fédéral parce que senna sakho mais je
pense qu'on en serait pas gratuit là
bon des boks poursuit vous dites vote
plus vraisemblables ce soit lundi soir -
qu'on rattrape du poker pour l'instant
nous dit début de semaine n'est
probablement pas triste mais on n'a pas
de précision de plusieurs être plus
clair demain où on en est au niveau de
la sécurité très bien louis merci
beaucoup on se reparle plus tard au
téléjournal
pascal robidas on parle des arrestations
depuis le début il y en a eu soixante
dix ça c'était le compte à 15h30 il doit
en avoir beaucoup plus que ça parce
qu'on en a vu un en direct depuis une
bonne dizaine alors voilà il ya beaucoup
d'arrestations
c'est un chiffre assez conservateur dans
des circonstances et je vais vous
montrer pourquoi parce que la file à
côté de moi ce n'est pas une file de
clients qui veulent entrer au centre
national des arts
coloniale bahia venu mais plutôt des
personnes qui étaient dans la barricade
où se trouvait tout à l'heure mon
collègue sébastien saint françois et qui
ont été mises en état d'arrestation par
les policiers voyez qu'il ya de
nombreuses personnes et au cours de la
dernière demi heure je peux vous dire
patrice que la file a pratiquement
quintuplé et ça continue toujours
d'arriver les gens attendent à
l'extérieur c'est très long peut-être
vous montrer les deux dames qu'il ya au
début de la file d'abord bon on parle
d'une dame qui a un certain âge avec une
demoiselle à ses côtés une jeune fille
un peu plus jeunes et qui visiblement on
la regarde depuis de tolar et qui a
extrêmement froid donc c'est un
processus qui est long et policiers ce
qu'ils font avec ces gens qui sont
arrêtés les prennent à leur leader droit
les chefs d'accusation qui seront
éventuellement déposées contre eux et
par la suite on les apporte dans un
panier à salade les paniers que vous
voyez le véhicule avec les lettrages
police bleu et blanc ben c'est un
véhicule où se trouve actuellement des
manifestants réfractaire qui ne voulait
pas quitter les lieux malgré les
nombreux avertissements et les chefs
d'accusation assez sérieux faut le dire
qu'ils peuvent être déposées contre eux
s'ils refusent d'obtempérer aux ordres
policiers n'y a pas mal voyez ici
plusieurs policiers
écoutez on pourrait facilement vous
estimer le nombre de personnes arrêtées
à une centaine
mais c'est un chef con con vous avance
toute réserve parce qu'il ya eu des
personnes qui ont été déplacées dans des
centres de détention d'autres qui
affluent et vous voyez également qu'il
ya des policiers qui rentrent du de la
barricade et qui sont relevés également
par d'autres collègues on est vraiment
dans une autre perspective que celle de
sébastien saint françois mais du même
lieu et vous constaterez aussi que la
plupart des gens arrêtés près ne semble
pas prendre la situation au sérieux on
rigole on nous saluent de la main à la
caméra et c'est peut-être après
discussion avec les changements
peut-être réaliser ces personnes qui
vont faire face à la justice dans les
circonstances oui mais c'est mieux comme
ça que c'est plus paisible disons que de
se faire bousculer tout à fait aux
manifestants merci beaucoup pascal je
vais aller on va
analyser avec stéphanie chouinard
madeleine blé morin sébastien bovet
sébastien vous vous attendez je le dis
en deux parenthèses et manifestations
non plus ce soir mais demain si je
comprends bien
c'est un woodstock devant le parlement
auquel convie les spectateurs à
woodstock donc festif en principe mais
les policiers sont prêts et donc ils ont
les leçons de tahoua qu'ils ont pu tirer
pour éviter que la situation de troy ne
se reproduise à québec donc en principe
cela devrait se dérouler dans le calme
ça s'était déroulée dans le calme il ya
deux semaines aussi on espère répéter
peut-être la question ses tiroirs
combien de personnes vont venir à québec
cette fois ci alors que le décor au film
en étant là qu'on a vu vous parliez de
québec un manifestant qui tendait n'y un
bouquet de fleurs il ya des photographes
de presse quand tu prends des photos
d'aller voir ça à la une de plusieurs
journaux demain peut-être madeleine
bonsoir c'est fanny à chouinard bonsoir
à vous ce qui me frappe parlons de
l'intervention policière une seconde ce
qui me frappe madeleine et stéphanie et
sébastien c'est vraiment la patience on
a décidé on a opté pour une une
opération lente méticuleuse mais avec le
moins de force possible cessera pas
madeleine quand même oui et j'entendais
un de vos experts dire on est quand même
dans un quartier résidentiel et c'est ce
qui a marqué les veines jours
d'occupation si on peut utiliser ce mot
là c'est qu'il y avait des gens à ottawa
qui était vraiment dérangé par la
présence des manifestants mais si on
commence à acheter des gaz lacrymogènes
à envoyer de l'eau de force disperser
les manifestants on peut finalement
perturber encore une fois les quartiers
résidentiels des gens qui habitent tout
près du centre ville tout près de la
colline du parlement donc j'imagine que
ça fait partie de l'équation d'essayer
de garder le calme le plus possible pour
éviter que ça dégénère entre autres au
sein des quartiers résidentiels certains
pays européens certaines villes
européennes c'est fanny chouinard qui
pourrait venir prendre des leçons là de
patience
oui certainement on voit
qu'effectivement la police et est très
patiente on a vu aussi dans le courant
de la journée les manifestants à
certains égards botuli utilisé des
enfants comme boucliers humains pour se
placer en crue et les corps policiers
donc on comprend pourquoi la police agit
de façon chirurgicale comme le disait
l'un d'eux de vos invités tout à l'heure
on veut à tout prix éviter qu'il y ait
des blessés on veut éviter l'escaladé de
la violence on a quand même vu du poivre
de cayenne utilisé mais on demeure le
très très tranquille de ce côté là et
dans les dernières minutes ce que j'ai
remarqué aussi c'est que les corps
policiers apparaissent maintenant avec
des bâtons à la main et ça plus tôt dans
la journée on voyait pas ça donc on voit
que on est patient mais on commence
quand même à se préparer peut-être à la
soirée où on attend ce qui est un peu
plus de grabuge et on veut avancer
thierry bourdieu et marc fait savoir
budget l'important dans une opération
elle peut être très longue mais elle ne
peut jamais paralysés par les
manifestants passaient là que ça dérape
et il ya des reculs on veut continuer
les chevaux tout à l'heure on est en
seine quand même rare
heureusement il n'y a pas tant de ces
grandes manifestations
où les chevaux sont venus scinder en
deux le groupe bon là le débat sur la
loi sur les mesures d'urgence maintenant
du côté policier c'est clair puis marcel
savard nous disait hier nous le répète
aujourd'hui pierre bourdieu également il
ya des gens qui se connaissent les
opérations qu'ils disent 112 est de ça
nous aide ou on est debout madeleine
dans l'analyse de du recours à cette loi
le gouvernement quand même eu de la
difficulté à expliquer exactement
pourquoi c'était nécessaire donc que ce
soit utile j'en doute pas et je pense
que personne va en douter là le seuil
que le gouvernement doit atteindre pour
invoquer cette loi là ce qui doit voir
une menace à la sécurité à la vie à la
souveraineté et que les outils
législatifs
traditionnelles ne suffisent pas donc si
ce que le gouvernement a dit finalement
que il fallait désigner des zones où
c'était interdit de manifester il
fallait gelé des comptes bancaires il
fallait permettre à des forces et des
remorqueuses à venir en aide est-ce que
c'était nécessaire ou c'était utile s'en
va pouvoir en débattre au parlement
d'ici à d'ici au vote et il y aura par
la suite une enquête dans l'iss dans
l'année qui va suivre la fin des mesures
d'urgence pour finalement analyser tout
ça c'est une première en patrice même si
la double la loi dadt ya plus de trente
ans on est encore en train de déterminer
les contours de cette fois là dans le
pratico pratique et c'était difficile je
trouve de déterminer où était la barre
est ce qu on a atteint le seuil oui ou
non mais j'ai trouvé que justin trudeau
dans son discours hier ne pas vraiment
bien expliquer ou aurait peut-être pu
mieux expliquer le plainois mieux
plaider pourquoi cette loi là était
absolument nécessaire et pas seulement
utile ben c'est une très très bon point
que vous apportez là parce que bien je
lis des comptes bancaires pouvoir
pouvoir
prendre les camions leur permis
effectivement ça va aider la façon qu'on
connaît c'est très utile
forcer les remorqueurs saas et revenus
beaucoup les gens peuvent dire c'est un
détail c'est pas nécessairement un
détail parce qu'il faut les falaises il
faut les enlever un jour si les
remorqueurs
refuge et on tournait en rond c'est
fanny china utile oui nécessaire selon
vous ouais le chef de police barre
aujourd'hui je pense à faire un beau
cadeau à justin trudeau en disant si on
n'avait pas eu les trois niveaux de
mesures d'urgence au niveau municipal
provincial et fédéral on n'aurait pas
été en mesure d'avoir l'action qui se
passe au centre-ville d'ottawa
aujourd'hui mais effectivement comme le
dit madeleine on agents sont grises ici
et du point de vue du gouvernement on
n'a pas été aussi convaincant qu'on
aurait pu l'être pour justifier
l'utilisation des mesures d'urgence
comme on l'a vu aussi depuis les trois
quatre derniers jours il ya un certain
nombre d'éléments qui ont été bien en
place qui était du registre du
gouvernement provincial avait pas besoin
de du de la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence fédérale pour aller de l'avant
tout ce qui a trait au permis de
conduire tout ce qui a trait aux plaques
d'immatriculation des véhicules qui sont
sur place seul le gouvernement fort et
si elle aurait eu la possibilité
d'avancer avec ces mesures là il ya déjà
deux trois semaines il y avait décidé de
ne pas le faire oui effectivement ils
ont décidé de le faire ta en fait tout
est arrivé tard qu'on rappelle sébastien
qu'à l'origine de tout ça puis une celle
d'avesnes ou rappelé hier on les a quand
même vu venir de la colombie britannique
le chef de police d'ottawa ça vaut
rester l'énigme et il ya eu cette espèce
de complaisance au début entre les
forces policières et sur cette mouvance
anti mesures sanitaires qui a fait que
on les a laissés campile oui et on
aurait dû mieux se préparer je pense que
c'est l'erreur de base de les avoir
laissé s'installer avec leur spa et
autres campements qu'ils ont réussi à
installer et on ne connaît pas toute
l'histoire à candresse que la volonté
politique
derrière la police était de les laisser
venir manifester pensons pas qu'ils
allaient s'installer peut-être qu'on
saura un jour mais c'est sûr que le
leadership exercé par le chef le
leadership exercé par le maire watson et
par doctor rossi ont été pratiquement
absents dans les 20 premiers jours
jusqu'à ce que le message soit envoyé
que la récréation est finie mais qu'on
passait aux choses sérieuses notamment
avec la loi sur les mesures de bon par
des mois de québec on a parlé rapidement
on a érigé je pense qu'on a ce qu'on a
des images je sais pas son et d'image
mais peu importe on a érigé comme la
dernière fois
ddm m -ad en neige et paraît se bat
c'est chez moi québec pour éviter que
les manifestants n'avaient dans un
certains endroits on va tenir sa serre
et encore demain la wii puis on le maire
de québec quand on parle de la
comparaison entre ottawa et québec c'est
noir et blanc c'est à dire que les
policiers se sont préparés en amont le
maire envoyer des messages aussi cette
semaine il a fait modifier des
règlements pack barbecue à ciel ouvert
pas de consommation d'alcool non plus
vous verrez pas de ce pas être érigé à
québec donc on les laissera pas
s'installer évidemment on a des leçons
de terroir d'un cocon petit pillon on a
cet avantage là à québec mais disons que
tout dans le mode d'emploi de gestion de
manif 101 a été bien appliqué à québec
et a été mal appliquée probablement
tahoua et donc le contraste est frappant
mais on laissera pas les manifestants
s'installer à québec est-ce qu'il veut
s'installer peut-être pas non plus la
dernière fois ils sont partis
oui c'est ça ils sont revenus le
lendemain ils ont été exemplaires eux
aussi peuvent vous dire c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a pas eu de débordement n'y a
pas eu d'affrontement les policiers ont
pas eu besoin de mettre leurs
équipements anti-émeutes et ainsi de
suite donc peut-être on présume que ça
va bien se passer aussi en fait c'est
très bien merci beaucoup on se reparle
au téléjournal
merci
de vos analyses je veut boucler cette
émission spéciale avant d'aller à voter
les journaux et autres
ce qui sera diffusée sur rd je veux
retourner sur le terrain
je sébastien saint-françois si vous
m'entendez donc on sentait la une ne il
ya quelques secondes une volonté
d'avancer encore on a vu cette image
donnée par pascal robin est assez
impressionnant de la centaine
d'arrestations
donc on continue
oui on est l'opération continue patrice
mais comme matt d'opérations vous
invitez vous l'ont dit aussi je pense
qu'ils seront d'accord la dépose des
fois la pause qu'on a vécu je veux dire
au cours des 15 dernières minutes ça a
servi entre autres à remplacer beaucoup
d'agents de première ligne par exemple
les gens de la sûreté du québec qui
étaient devant nous un peu à gauche de
la ligne eh ben ils ont été remplacés
par des policiers entre autres d'ottawa
et de toronto et là ben vous entendez la
foule qui crie des mouvements d'humeur
comme ça qui commence et qui qui
s'arrête à certains moments on sait pas
toujours pourquoi ça commence dès fois
seulement dans un petit cocon peu pour
voir ce qu'on dit sur une pause dites
moi une chose sébastien si les gens
qu'on voit bien dans les images en
direct devant château laurier si les
policiers arrivent à 10 soit dispersée
ils ont chassé ces gens là cet
attroupement là est ce que y en a de la
même taille devant le parlement aussi
les gens qui étaient devant le parlement
qui sont maintenant devant le château
on vous montre patrice les gens qui sont
derrière il y en a encore qui sont
devant le parlement il ya indéniablement
groupe convoi qui sont arrivés du
parlement mais là aussi ça je le présume
un peul des gens qui sont arrivés se
sont ramenés
probablement après qu'ils aient vu les
vies des images qui ont qui ont été
diffusées qui ont circulé sur les médias
sociaux des interventions de ce matin et
des gens qui ont par des manifestants
professionnels il ya des gens qui sont
pas n'ont pas l'air d'avoir été ici très
longtemps entre vous et moi les gens qui
nous écoutent
il ya des gens qui ont l'air à faire une
visite pour pour venir voir ce qui ce
passe bien sur la ligne de front et
après ça qui retraite donc il ya encore
énormément de gens là il faut pas se
tromper il ya plusieurs plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui sont ici un
groupe dur qui semble émis en bon
québécois se colletailler avec les
agents de première ligne pardonnez moi
l'expression
est ce que ces gens là c'est ce noyau
dur au milieu de la ligne restera ici
très longtemps
ça faudra voir il ya un peu moins de
gens première ligne patrice je vous le
confirme mais a quand même plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui sont toujours
ici ouais alors
quand vous dites il ya des gens qui ont
peut-être été découragés par la régie
les l'image de cette arrestation du
camionneur qui étaient à l'intérieur et
une policière après trois fois a perdu
patience puis si la vitre et l'a arrêté
c'est genre d'image ce genre d'image qui
disent qui fait réfléchir des gens aussi
la société ces gens alors on et qui soit
le noyau dur en les voilà
alors le policier qui a voilà qui a
fracassé la vitre quasi monsieur on sort
je peux pas vous dire les dix fois je
voulais demander trois fois c'est
terminé on ça alors et ça c'est des gens
patrice qui sont souvent à l'intérieur
qui celui là pour pour que son essai ces
images soient déjà diffusés sur les
réseaux sociaux ça veut dire qu'il a
déjà été arrêté et a seulement qu'une
seulement qu'un corps m'a vraiment une
intersection où ça peut être arrivé là
je présume un peu mais je pense que je
lis pas trop de me tromper c'est au-delà
il voulait pas quitter des 100 camions
comme d'autres camionneurs ont décidé de
le faire
les policiers vous le voyez le lien
politique acquis tapas à se mettre deux
à trois fois exact sur le coup en direct
sur le terrain y a pas grand monde qui
voit cette image là parce que les
policiers forment déjà ce moment là un
cordon sécuritaire autour de l'agent qui
fait son intervention mais sur les
réseaux je peux vous a été vu les
horaires exacts et voilà donc et ça
demain matin parce que là vous allez
aller un jour dormir ces bassins quand
même atteint je le rappelle aux gens qui
nous écoutent tout ce ne sera pas
terminé marcel savoir l'a bien expliqué
pierre yves bord du havre c'est une
opération longue la patiente méthodique
aux voeux et à les ondes pardon mais
quand cette zone que l'on voit
actuellement sera dégagé ben alors
peut-être ça va s'accélérer un peu quand
même et demain c'est pas fini sébastien
soyons clair avec les gens là
ouais c'est pas fini et je dirais même
pour la zone qui est dégagée déjà les de
la première ou la deuxième jambe qui ont
été dégagés des manifestants j'ai perçu
fils ainsi que des chiffres des sous
genres et animale qui boucla mais bon
voilà donc même si au delà elles sont
dégagés de manifestants
les camions ils sont encore là donc il
faut que les dépanneurs arrive souvent
sous accord policière qu'ils attachent
ces camions s'assure qu'ils aient pas
d'avarice à ceux qui a pas de bris et
qu'on puisse les sortir de l'endroit où
ils sont ça va prendre des heures et ça
et je m'avance leur meilleur il va
prendre des heures vraiment à dégager
chacune de ces intersections de leur
camion donc on va on peut vous on peut
dire
patrice vous et moi au service de
tromperie qui va avoir encore certaines
zones à dégager une vanne facile mais on
en a pour plusieurs jours a remarqué des
véhicules remorqués des sourires
remorqué des fourgonnettes
vérifier qu'ils sont en état de rouler
s'il faut pas les mettre sur une
plateforme roulante ça on est loin
d'avoir terminé le mont point de la
situation malheureuse je dirais c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a dégagé connaissez un
peu ottawan fois qu'on a dégagé devant
le château laurier et qu'on a remarqué
les véhicules qui sont à l'intersection
vous voyez des policiers à ma gauche en
ce moment d wen ont joué
très bien voilà et merci à notre
cameraman toi qui as juste l'exposition
là mais lorsqu'on aura dégager le devant
du château laurier et la rue rideau qui
descend jusqu'au centre commercial le
centre rideau safram parties une partie
importante du centre-ville d'ottawa qui
sera dégagée qui pourra probablement
redonner un semblant de début de vie
normale on pourra rouvrir des commerces
qui était à toutes fins pratiques
enclavé qu'on ne pouvait pas atteindre
depuis maintenant presque trois semaines
donc petit à petit en dégageant les
manifestants en remarquant les véhicules
en ouvrant certaines intersections c'est
comme ça que à la fois services de
police l'administration municipale et
les citoyens vont retrouver leur ville
c'est une opération je rappelle aux gens
qui étaient peut-être pas avec nous au
début qui est dirigé par la police
d'ottawa et à la police provinciale et à
la sûreté du québec le camion il ya la
police de toronto et à la police de new
york et la police de pilleurs donc beau
et de la grc joly dit beaucoup beaucoup
de policiers au moins un email
au moins aimé elle y avait 17 ans à peu
près 500 manifestants plusieurs camions
alors à suivre on a vu pascal robidas
pascal vous vouliez il reste deux
minutes à cette partie des missions vous
vouliez nous montrer quoi les policiers
qui lisent les droits je crois baisse
exactement on lit les droits aux
personnes à rester on les fouilles et
ensuite on les embarque dans un panier à
salade que vous voyez également dans
l'image qu'on vous montre un direct et
par la suite les gens sont amenés dans
un centre de détention pour
interrogatoire
donc on commence à peine à rencontrer
des personnes qui sont en état
d'arrestation et on vous montre en fin
d'émission une idée de la file qui a
grossi encore depuis qu'on s'est parlé
la dernière fois un patrice donc c'est
donc dire que l'intervention policière
donne des résultats et la barricade où
se trouve notre collègue sébastien
françois éventuellement sera démantelée
parce que on est en train de mettre en
état d'arrestation les personnes les
plus résistantes qui refuse de quitter
les lieux g jour boullier la méga vous
aviez raison tout à l'heure il ya une
centaine
le chef de police à 15h30 parler de 70
arrestations
il y en a plus aujourd'hui il y en a
plus ça c'est le moment aussi merci
beaucoup merci pascal on se reparle ou
télévisuelle sébastien vous m'entendez
je vous remercie je vous retrouve au
téléjournal j'avais dit quelque chose
d'important
sans eux on est on est rien on montre
rien le caméraman vos caméraman
travaillent avec vous c'est pas dans
votre cas
oui travail phénoménal ouais alors bravo
chapeau à tous nos caméraman qui sont
sur le terrain avoue bien sûr sens ça va
ça va de soi qui est là depuis tôt ce
matin c'est pas fini parce que voter les
journaux mesdames et messieurs vont
suivre à l'instant dans toutes les
régions du pays dont le nôtre bien sûr
et je vous retourne donc à quelques
secondes ou à très bientôt merci d'avoir
été là a questionné
bienvenue au téléjournal après 22 jours
de siège les policiers ont lancé leur
grande opération libération du centre
ville d'ottawa
invoquant le club
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous le voyez mesdames et
messieurs l'opération est en cours
depuis tôt ce matin on a utilisé il ya
une heure on va vous montrer sa des
chevaux pour tenter de diviser un groupe
de manifestants devant le château
laurier ottawa il ya cette dernière
poche plus important d'une opération qui
est méticuleuse qui est lente on veut et
c'est l'objectif d'utiliser le moins de
force possible
tout se passe au centre ville on a
subdivisé cette zone rouge en dix
petites secondes et unes après les
autres les eaux numérotée unes après les
autres on les en chassent les
manifestants soit en leur disant de
partir soit en les arrêtant il ya déjà
cette heure-ci 18 heures une centaine de
manifestants qui ont été arrêtés on va
aller sur le terrain bien sûr avec nos
journalistes sont là depuis le début
si c'est françois pascal robidas mais
d'abord qui arrive bourdiaux à sous
commissaire à la retraite de la
gendarmerie royale du canada monsieur
bordure on a vu depuis ce matin des
images de policiers très patient et
méthodique très nombreux comment vous
pouvez expliquer à des gens qui naissent
- le type d'intervention qu'on a choisi
c'est ce que l'on le directeur de 1 par
intérim de la police de ville d'ottawa
et n'y est clair que les policiers ont
un plan d'action c'est du long terme
c'est de rechercher une solution le plus
pacifique possible les policiers
comprennent très bien que les gens sont
très émotifs autour de toute la charge
sociale qui existe pour la vaccination
les mesures sanitaires dont des
policiers essayent de de progresser pour
pouvoir évidemment ultime en clair et
comme vous l'avez expliqué le tout la le
secteur du centre ville de la ville
d'ottawa mais le fond de méthodiquement
en vie jusqu'à maintenant il n'ya aucun
rapport de personnes de blessés à
l'exception d'une blessure mineure pour
un poids de 6 donc dans ce contexte esrp
que les forces de l'ordre opèrent de
façon progressive et s'assure de gagner
le terrain en évitant le minimum
deux confrontations mais jusqu'à
maintenant le nombre d'arrestations
quand même assez impressionnant on parle
de plus de 200 arrestations
il ya plus que b véhicules qui ont été
saisis jusqu'à maintenant et l'opération
se déroule comme prévu comme le
directeur medic je le disais on a
subdivisé la zone rouge de town 10 ou 11
sous secteurs on est rendu avec le vent
château laurier au 2ème tête début du
troisième ça va prendre du temps encore
oui mais là le noeud durs de 7 cette
occupation l'eau et tout le secteur qui
qui est devant le parlement y environ
deux ou trois ans rue devant le
parlement et c'est là que les camions
sont localisées que les infrastructures
que les occupants ont bâti au cours des
trois dernières semaines c'est dans ce
secteur là qui concentre et les purs et
durs et c'est vers là que les policiers
se dirige présentement à de façon
progressive et de façon quand même
relativement pacifique ce qui est tous
impressionnants c'est tout le volet
logistique
puisqu'on parle de sept corps policier
qui coordonnent leurs efforts ensemble
et qui sont évidemment bien supervisé
avec un centre de commandement qui peut
jauger le mouvement de foule pour
appliquer la pression nécessaire pour
pouvoir progresser tranquillement et
l'important monsieur boudrias et de ne
pas être paralysés parce qu'on le dit
c'est une opération qui est lente mais
qui ne doit progresser quand même art
après on peut pas se permettre de
reculer
exactement et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que vers environ quatre heures cet
après midi à ie mouvement de foule qui
était quand même très agressif vers les
policiers des positions poussé mon
sentais que j'avais une pression énorme
d'appliquer sur les policiers de la 1re
ligne qui étaient là et c'est à ce
moment là qu un peu plus tôt une
intervention avec la cavale et qui ni
plus ni moins ok une zone entre les
manifestants et les policiers et à ce
moment là le leur sac qui y étaient qui
a suivi l'intervention de la cavalerie
permet aux policiers d'avancer
rapidement pu gagner du terrain
rapidement donc dans ce contexte là le
déploiement de cavaliers quelque chose
qu'on ne voit pas souvent lorsqu'il ya
des manifestations mais c'est un outil
utile puis dans la mesure du possible
qui évite aussi des confrontations
et une utilisation encore de gaz
lacrymogène donc les policiers font un
travail méticuleux il ya 20 ans mais les
méticuleusement en évitant évidemment de
blesser les gens qui doivent effectuer
des arrestations qui dans la mesure du
possible sont quand même su contrôler et
de façon pacifique mais c'est une
déploiement logistique quand même
considérable parce qu'on regarde la du
long terme à mon avis à moi puis à la
vie de max helmand aux confins de la
sûreté du québec c'est que ignore on
regarde à une période de 48 à 72 heures
et donc de déploiement policier doit
être dosé pour s'assurer que le terek on
a gagné on ne leur père il faut qu'à 10
du défaut que des renforts cette nuit
fait pourra se tourner c'est plutôt de
deux policiers donc on peut pas se
permettre de mettre tout le monde en
même temps
merci beaucoup monsieur bourgeois de vos
lumières ça nous aide à comprendre ce
type d'opération policière merci merci
au revoir au dessus
sébastien c'est françois je vous
retrouve vous êtes vraiment eu la housse
si le lieu le plus chaud ou là c'est
devant château laurier aussi là où on a
envoyé la cavalerie tout à l'heure pour
disperser enfin pour scinder en deux le
groupe de manifestants
ont répété les policiers à cheval de du
service de police de toronto qui ont été
amenés ici en renfort ils ont été
utilisés à deux reprises ce soir pour
créer un espace comme le disait votre
invité entre la première ligne de
policiers la première ligne de
manifestants manifestants il y en a
beaucoup il y en aura encore plus au
début de la soirée 3 4 5 me de profonds
a certainement ses projets les uns les
autres pour résister à l'avancée à
l'avancée des policiers grand moment il
ya eu une charge de la par une charge
conserver une chance plutôt un mouvement
de cavalerie qui est venu s'immiscer
entre la première ligne des policiers de
la 1re ligne des manifestants pour créer
un certain espoir que les policiers ont
ensuite occupé cela plus d'une manière
de la mer dans ce genre gagner du
terrain par contre lors de ce deuxième
mouvement je pense que vous avez vu des
images où on va vous démontrer il ya un
incident qui est survenu à cheval qui
semble avoir glissé qui s'est relevé on
l'a perdue pendant un instant dans nos
caméras est ce que on sent le comprend
maintenant c'est que y'a un manifestant
qui aurait tenté de blesser le cheval
qui a été arrêté avec une service de
police d'ottawa avec une bicyclette
imaginer le service de police d'ottawa a
envoyé sur twitter une déclaration
expliquant que cette personne là avaient
été arrêtés qu'elle ferait face à une
accusation pour avoir tenté de blesser
un animal de service une accusation qui
peut s'appliquer aussi par cas de chiens
de maître chien ou de chiens qui sont
blessés par exemple par des prévenus ou
des suspects qu'on tente d'arrêter dans
ce cas ci c'est le cas d'un cheval en
service celui du service de police de
toronto donc une personne arrêtée
spécifiquement pour sa 7 ce mouvement de
cavalerie patrice g a surpris plusieurs
puis d'un coup j'ai vu lors du g 20 mois
à toronto yann plus d'une dizaine
d'années deçà des mouvements cavalerie
qu'aider complètement différent qui est
d'attirer pour but de repousser les
manifestants mais qui sortait carrément
de la ligne qui rentrait un peu au trot
presque au galop pour eux pour faire
part aux manifestants parce que si c'est
des chevaux qui presque physiquement on
séparait la ligne des policiers et la
ligne des manifestants très bien
sébastien saint-françois merci beaucoup
on va continuer avec vous à suivre tout
ça devant le château laurier ottawa
pascal robidas vos images nous ont
permis de constater on avait dépassé le
nombre de 70 arrestations d'hier une
centaine
approximativement parce que vous êtes
vous avez une vue sur cette file de gens
qui attendent qu'ils ont été arrêtées et
qu'attend
exactement au lait sur les mêmes lieux
que notre collègue sébastien saint
françois mais à l'arrière parmi les
opérations policières est ce que vous
voyez ce sont des manifestants
réfractaires à obéir aux ordres a
obtempéré à l'ordre de quitter les lieux
du blocus au centre-ville d'ottawa est
ce que vous voyez ce sont tous des des
manifestants en état d'arrestation ce
qui se passe c'est que on les menottes
ont leur lit leurs droits on leur aurait
ensuite on les transporte dans un panier
à salade pour les années par la suite
dans un centre de détention donc ce sont
toutes des personnes qui étaient
installés dans la barricade qui a été
construite où se trouvaient ses vastes
et saint françois et qui ont été
arrêtées en marge des mouvements
policiers la cavalerie vous en avez
parlé précédemment et qui se retrouve
maintenant face à la justice des chefs
d'accusation entre autres pour se
retrouver dans un périmètre où il est
interdit d'y être et surtout de
manifester la manifestation faut-il le
rappeler a été déclaré illégal donc ces
personnes ont refusé d'obtempérer et se
retrouve maintenant menotté questionné
par les policiers ont leurs vies leurs
droits et par la suite bien la suite des
choses c'est la justice qui s'occupe du
reste donc c'est vraiment un point de
vue à l'arrière scène d'où se trouve
sébastien saint françois on a pu voir
également des policiers se prépare et
qu'on veut vous voir vous le voyez on
est juste à côté de l'hôtel westin au
centre-ville d'ottawa et c'est à cet
endroit que les policiers enfilent leurs
uniformes pour aller ensuite relevé
d'autres collègues à la barricade qu'ils
ont tenu un peu la ligne policière
durant tout l'après midi parce qu'il
faut le dire les policiers ont été
relativement patients ils ont été lents
au moins et quatre heures de temps avant
de passer à l'action et de procéder à
des arrestations mais visiblement la la
file qui qui est à côté de moi a grossi
ok tu plais en l'espace de plus de temps
patrice très bien merci parce que c'est
steve bell le chef de police d'ottawa
qui a fait le point un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui en disant qu' on était rendu
à 70 arrestations il a dit une chose
importante et lise allard qui avait eu
aucun blessé
blessé mineur très mineur chez les
policiers aucun chez les manifestants
jusqu'ici à 18 heures après plus de 12
heures d'opération ça se passe bien
ça se passe relativement biais comme
vous le disiez on parle de plus de mille
policiers qui sont dans ce centre ville
d'ottawa en encore assiégée par les
manifestants au moins 500 manifestants
et un seul blessé se serait un policier
mise à part ce cheval de laquelle
valérie qui aurait reçu une bicyclette
comme l'indiquait la police et donc on a
vu des gens dans les images que nous
montrer pascal en files d'attentes en
attendant de recevoir
en fait d'être mis dans des paniers à
salade mais mise à part sa combi et
d'arrestations officiellement à 15h45 le
chef de police parlait de 70
arrestations c'est beaucoup par sept
corps policiers dans la ville d'ottawa
ont dit que ça en fait le chef belle qui
disait le chef de la police d'ottawa que
des corps policiers de partout au pays
sont intervenus pour les lieux cette
opération policière aujourd'hui à ottawa
et que sans la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence sans les décrets qu'elle a
permis et bien ça ça ne se serait pas
produit comme on l'a vu
somme toute assez pacifiquement où il ya
eu des échauffourées entre les
manifestants et les policiers mais
l'opération la vue d'ici de l'hôtel
westin sur le sur le balcon ça c'est pas
assez tranquillement mais sûrement il ya
pas eu beaucoup de blessés alors tout ça
c'est on peut écouter justement le chef
gérard qualifie de grand succès très
bien oui voilà
adopter
sa loi sur les mesures d'urgence dit il
on arrive ne serait pas en mesure de
mener une opération comme celle là
aujourd'hui selon ce chef de police on
va en reparler plus tard avec nos
analyses politiques merci beaucoup elisa
tahoua et louis blouin bon ben justement
les travaux le débat sur cette loi des
mesures d'urgence devaient se poursuivre
mais chose
très maurer au canada le parlement a
fermé ses portes oui parce que le
président de la chambre des communes
n'était pas certain que la sécurité des
députés pouvaient être assuré pendant
cette journée d'intervention policière
alors il a dit tout le monde reste à la
maison aujourd'hui les parties étaient
d'accord avec ça maintenant la question
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en vont
reprendre les débats sur ces mesures
d'urgence parce qu'on est dans un
marathon parlementaire est-ce qu'on va
ajouter des heures de débat dans la nuit
cette fin de semaine pour qu'on passe et
on verra bien est-ce qu'on peut siéger
en virtuel la difficulté c'est vaut
quand même qu'il ya dix ans employé au
parlement pour faire fonctionner tout ça
alors ça c'est pas régler encore au plus
tôt les députés pourraient revenir
demain les sénateurs c'est lundi
seulement l'autre question importante
quand le vote sur ces mesures d'urgence
parce qu'il devait avoir lieu lundi
prochain à 20h est-ce qu'il sera retardé
ou est-ce qu'on va simplement enlever du
temps de débat on verra bien et l'autre
point d'interrogation que fera le npd
qui a dit qu'il allait appuyer le
gouvernement pour maintenir ses pouvoirs
d'urgence en place lors de ce vote si la
situation s'est stabilisée à ottawa
lundi ce que le npd va sentir qu'il a
encore la légitimité pour faire ça
écoutons le chef adjoint du npd suivi un
député conservateur et d'un blocus qui
eux de leur côté sont opposés à ces
mesures d'urgence
ci a plus d'occupation illégale c'est
plus de blocus s'il ya plus d'objets
pour voter pour cette loi là le npd on
pourrait considérer
voter autrement dans ces situations
l'exigent je crois pas que la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence a été l'élément
déclencheur de cette opération qu'on a
ce matin chose certaine c'est bien de
voir que les policiers font en sorte de
libérer la rue wellington s'il y avait
eu une action concertée des forces
policières avaient
avec une classe politique qui aurait
pris rapidement ses responsabilités et
loge vise particulièrement le vent en
amont fédéral parce que senna sakho mais
je pense qu'on n'en serait pas rendu là
le gouvernement plaide que même si tout
revient au calme lundi
la loi est quand même utile pour
quelques temps où absolument parce
qu'ils gardaient ce qu'on est capable de
faire on est capable de geler des
comptes bancaires notamment et 10 il y
en a des comptes de geler actuellement
le gouvernement veut pas dire combien
ils disent que ça fait une différence
ils disent que dalkia d'ottawa ils ont
été capables d'en joindre des
remorqueurs des opérateurs de
remorqueuse pour être capable de dégager
ces camions là aussi ça donne des
pouvoirs pour des amendes supplémentaire
des peines d'emprisonnement pour
interdire les rassemblements alors c'est
quand même assez vaste et le
gouvernement pense qu'il faudra les
maintenir au delà du retour au calme à
ottawa si des manifestants par exemple
décidé de revenir d'aller retourner
bloquer un poste frontière de revenir à
ottawa ou autre là dessus je vous invite
à entendre le ministre françois philippe
champin
alors moi je pense que d'avoir ces deux
joueurs-là de toute façon limité dans le
temps on parle en vertu des lois de 30
jours dont ses limites et d'en tracer
cyr construit aussi au niveau
géographique et moi je passais la chose
responsable
merci louis donc le vote le vote pau
lundi soir sûrement pas quand mardi
c'est bon c'est pas le leader du
gouvernement en chambre a dit début de
semaine alors ça laisse une marge de
manoeuvre peut-être le duo mardi
effectivement ce serait vraisemblable
merci beaucoup louis algérois et puis
après la pause on continue notre
couverture avec ce qui se passe en
direct bien sûr retard on va aussi
parler de la ville de québec qui se
prépare à accueillir sa manifestation
demain à plus tard
[Musique]
on va faire un petit crochet par québec
parce qu'il ya une manifestation qui est
prévue demain raphaël beaumont doit donc
il ya déjà une poignée de manifestants
sans rien avoir et qu'ottawa bien sûr
mais arrivé à québec
wes patrice je vous dirais que c'est
beaucoup plus une soirée de préparation
que deux manifestations parce que de
pouvoir le voir par vous même il ya tant
qu un peu moins de nous vingtaine de
manifestants qui sont sur place son
talent en milieu d'après midi à québec
dont sont affairés principalement à la
préparation d'une heure montage d'une
scène qui vont servir à donner des
allocutions un spectacle lors de la
manifestation principale des opposants
mesures salutaires grosse produire ici
même à québec demain le tout s'est
déroulé dimanche plus étroite
surveillance policière parce que les
policiers ont refait un peu sensiblement
la même approche que lors des
manifestations précédentes
un peu plus tôt au mois de février c'est
à dire de plus bloqué l'accès
complètement la colline parlementaire
aux véhicules de seulement laissé les
manifestants les piétons circulez y'a
pas eu aucun poids lourd qui ne pu
accéder à la colline parlementaire
certains ont essayé de se frayer un
chemin mais rapidement les policiers ils
ont intercepté alors demandé de faire
demi-tour hawks encore une fois on a le
service de police de québec où il
vraiment allez y allez manchester pour
cette journée
ils me font bien chier je vais très
honnête mais pourquoi pourquoi parce que
parce que je pense qu'à un moment donné
faut que faut que ça cesse a je suis
d'accord qu'il ya des fois le
gouvernement fait pas forcément les
meilleures choses et je pense qu'en fait
c'est des prétextes pour autre chose ça
fait juste diviser la civil à la
population mais que ce soit avec
suspense que le gouvernement était en
train d'enlever les mesures non ça
devient méticuleux moment
on va suivre ça pour quand même
réalisé
oui oui vous venez d'entendre je demande
des citoyens à qui on a demandé qui
n'ont pas de lien avec la manifestation
on leur a demandé qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensaient justement de cette
manifestation qui survient alors que le
québec les bailleurs plusieurs mesures
sanitaires qui vont nous serons plus
appliquée au cours des prochaines
semaines comme les vues entendues
plusieurs qui comprenait pas le but de
cette manifestation qui doit se produire
demain merci
le président baden qui est toujours
aussi convainc
qu'il n'y aura pas qu'il y aura une
invasion russe
en ukraine
il est il était cette semaine il était
la semaine dernière qu'ils avaient même
dit les américains mercredi que vladimir
poutine allait aller attaquer à dire
bonsoir à washington alors une changent
pas d'idée la
non et patrice c'est la première fois
qu'en fait joe biden affirme qu'il est
convaincu que vladimir poutine va
envahir l'ukraine parce que jusqu'à
présent 10 est écoutée on sait pas ce
qui se passe dans la tête de vladimir
poutine il est toujours très
imprévisible mais là c'est clair il se
dit qu'ils se basent sur des
renseignements sur ses services de
renseignements qui sont extrêmement
précis donc toute cette constatation est
fondée si vous voulez et que la ville de
kiev serait la première cible kiev qui
est une population de près de 3 millions
d'habitants donc aujourd'hui joe biden a
parlé environ 15 minutes après avoir
discuté avec ses homologues européens de
l'alliance de l'otan également de
l'union européenne mais dit qu'ils
forment vraiment un véritable au front
uni contre la russie si jamais elle
envahi l'ukraine il affirme que veut
dire poutine depuis le début fait une
espèce de propagande de guerre se
présente un peu comme une victime vous
savez il ya de la violence en ukraine
dans l'est de l'ukraine vadimir poutine
affirme que c'est l'ukraine qui est en
train d'attaquer des ressortissants
ukrainiens pro russe et il affirme qu'en
fait la russie ne pourra que se défendre
joe biden a dit que tout ceci c'est de
la fabrication que vladimir poutine a
une idée bien en tête qui va envahir
l'ukraine et que là évidemment il a dit
qu'un front uni si si la russie envers
l'ukraine d'un seul pouce il va y avoir
des représailles écoutons extraits de
son discours
communiqué commun dès maintenant mustek
ce point
of rocks
au choix
et la grande crainte à z c'est que la
russie prenne prétexte d'un incident
parce qu'il y en a là ça fait deux jours
de suite il ya des tirs et des incidents
entre dans l'est du pays
où exactement ce qu'ils ont dit que le
cessez le feu le cessez-le-feu a été
violé plus de 500 fois vous savez que
l'accord de minsk normalement qui avait
dit qu'il y aura un cessez le feu entre
l'ukraine et la russie mais non là c'est
pas du tout respectée hier souvenez-vous
ce jardin d'enfants là qui a été
bombardé et bien les russes il accuse
l'ukraine ils disent que l'ukraine et
militarisé grâce aux américains qui sont
en train d'essayer d'envahir tout l'est
qui est aujourd'hui fait partie de la
russie seront évidemment vladimir
poutine et qu'en fait les russes ne font
que se défendre alors là la russie
procède à l'évacuation de ressortissants
russes savait que la semaine dernière
ils ont émis des passeports plus de
600000 passeports à des ukrainiens pro
russes en leur disant venez en russie en
fait ils sont entrain de finalement
libéré un peu la place est ce que les
américains craignent c'est que c'est
peut-être un signe là qui va y avoir
peut-être une invasion qui va avoir en
tout cas de la violence à partir du
moment où ils sont en train de sortir
leurs ressortissants joe biden
aujourd'hui a dit écoutez la voix
diplomatique n'est pas épuisé
normalement le sécrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken doit
rencontrer sergueï lavrov son homologue
russe mercredi jeudi prochain donc ça
s'est confirmé évidemment ça c'est s'il
n'y a pas d'attaqué il n'y a pas de
greling d'attac de la part de la russie
ce que c'est ce que joe biden a voulu
préciser aujourd'hui également demain ou
président ukrainien va se rendre en
allemagne à munich alors évidemment
beaucoup de personnes craignent que
peut-être que vladimir poutine va
profiter de son absence pour agir
finalement donc il ya énormément de
spéculation des deux côtés que ce soit
de la russie que ce soit des états unis
il ya vraiment deux versions des faits
est évidemment dans ces situations là la
vérité souvent la plus grande même film
mais pour le moment les américains sont
persuadés là que dans quelques jours à
venir poutine va envahir l'ukraine merci
hazeb à washington on suit ça évidemment
merci beaucoup au revoir après la pause
on revient sur cette grande opération
policière à tahoua donc avec analyse
et sur le terrain nos reporters radio
[Musique]
je
d opinion claire de le fed en arrière
les analyses pertinentes nature la
chapelle royale mas est un plaisir
renouvelé sébastien bovet anime mort
d'une politique en semaine 12h30 ici rdi
quoi qu'il arrive
allô allô nouveau départ
allo motivation à l'eau possibilité à la
détermination
à l'eau confiance je vais dire confiance
alo'o meilleur de moi même
allo le monde
aidez à connecter des jeunes un monde de
possibilités donner un futur meilleur
point com cherchez-vous de l'espoir dans
un monde de douleur pour le soulagement
la marque a essayé en premier et salons
pas fiable et efficace la marque la plus
digne de confiance avec la croissance la
plus rapide que le soulagement commence
avec salon parce c'est un bon remède
vous avez du mal à trouver le véhicule
que vous désirez auto hebdo on a
toujours des dizaines de milliers à
vendre partout au québec c'est une
superbe façon de trouver super véhicules
super prix visitez auto hebdo
aujourd'hui être membre de la croix
médecine privée c'est avoir accès à la
plus importante équipe médicale privée
au québec un réseau de cliniques offrant
des services en médecine familiale
spécialisée et corporatives près de 60
médecins dont plusieurs spécialiste en
dermatologie chirurgie urologie
gynécologie et plus offrant une
accessibilité de soins dans les délais
les plus courts et ce partout au québec
nous prenons le temps de veiller à votre
santé voilà ce qui nous définit chez
lacroix médecine privée
les nouvelles boissons à base d'espresso
des thèmes sans faute avec des grains
100% arabica de première qualité et de
société
personnaliser et préparé minutieusement
juste pour toi ma chum et goûtent à
notre nouveau lattes et cannelle caramel
et avoine planète métal revivez 60 ans
de culture métal et hard rock à travers
tous ces groupes mythiques dans une
collection de livres inédits redécouvrez
tous les courants du hard rock
l'histoire des groupes et les secrets de
leur meilleur album le numéro 1 a cédé
ses 95 sous seulement se rétablir de la
pandémie signifie rebâtir une économie
qui apporte un soutien à ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin vous pouvez accéder dès
maintenant à des programmes de soutien
financier ciblé fait pour les
propriétaires d'entreprises admissibles
et les canadiens qui en ont besoin
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut bâtir une
économie plus résiliente
consulter canada.ca barres obliques le
coronavirus pour connaître les
programmes de soutien financier qui vous
sont offerts un message du gouvernement
du canada
[Musique]
nouveau sport préféré où que vous soyez
quel que soit votre sport trouvé une
photo paris sur ton est bête point net
alors depuis ce matin l'opération était
lancée ce seuil à 1h30 quand la
gendarmerie royale a lancé des chevaux
pour disperser
en partie mais surtout scindé en deux un
groupe de manifestants qui étaient
devant château laurier laurence martin
nous raconte la journée
[Musique]
les forces de l'ordre sonne la fin de la
récréation
après 22 jours d'occupation au
centre-ville d'ottawa les policiers
déployés par centaines commence à
reprendre du terrain
une opération massive coordonnée
méthodique où chaque centimètre
lentement gagné permet de s'accrocher de
plus en plus du coeur du blocage
manifestants qui résistent sont tout de
suite arrêté et emmené au poste pour
comparaître
[Applaudissements]
alors que des enfants se tiennent à deux
pas de la ligne policière des agents
casqués et masqués sont prêts à toute
éventualité
les tireurs d'élite observer les
mouvements de la foule
à quelques coins de rue de là des
camions sont déplacés
[Musique]
malgré tout les protestataires sont peu
près c'est parti je verrai pas comment
qui commencera à démanteler ils peuvent
pas on les gens vont se mettre à terre
on va s'asseoir ils vont totalement
pacifique lyon aucun motif de nous
renvoyer les manifestants font même des
chaînes humaines pour empêcher les
policiers d'avancé
ont créé notre propre ligne dans cette
femme venue du nord de l'alberta
d'autres espèrent que ces remparts de
neige qu'ils érigent freineront les
forces de l'ordre
mais au coeur du blocage l'opération
policière semble encore bien loin
jessica s'amuse avec sa petite april 3
ans comme elle le fait depuis des
semaines déjà si j'avais par exemple la
police commence à rentrer comment ça
marche pendulaire je pense que passer on
va vivre chaque minute par la minute
certains purs et durs ont d'ailleurs
toujours l'ambiance à la faire
mais en fin d'après midi la tension
monte près du parlement
la cavalerie pénètre dans la foule
et policiers repousse les manifestants
alors que les arrestations se
multiplient la nuit ne sera pas de tout
repos
si laurence partait radio canada ottawa
oui la nuit ne sera pas de tout repos
sébastien françois parce que c'est loin
d'être terminée il y encore quand même
pas mal de monde devant le château
laurier devant le parlement
tu te fais patrice des centaines de
manifestants encore devant château le
riz qui se tiennent eux ces
manifestantes devant des lignes de
policiers en ce moment selon ce sont des
agents de la police provinciale de
l'ontario entre autres sur visé police
de toronto aussi qui tiennent la
première ligne un groupe de mieux
manifestants moins important qu'aux
environs de 17 et puis ensuite 18 heures
sur le coup de 18 heures mais qui sont
toujours déterminés à faire valoir leurs
points et a résisté aux policiers même
s'ils perdent du terrain tranquillo en
manifestant parce que les policiers ils
ont des renforts ils ont des rotations
qui permet de remplacer les policiers
plus fatigués qui sont là depuis un
certain jour des forces fraîches
intervalles réguliers à ce moment ils
sont un endroit où ils ont atterri
disons cela comme ça il ya environ 2000
n'ont pas bougé son ensemble content de
pouvoir contenir la situation telle
qu'elle est en ce moment on est tout
juste que vous voyez un peu à gauche de
l'image recélant trie château laurier un
hôtel important ici à ottawa n'est
complètement à l'opposé de l'autre côté
de la rue
[Applaudissements]
ces nuages n'est pas très c'est
l'immeuble qui abrite le siège
temporaire du sénat c'est non aussi
d'anciens agents ce moment à cause de
toutes les rénovations qui a eu
évidemment l'immeuble est fermée il ya
des policiers à l'intérieur qui en
interdisent l'accès il ya des clôtures
qui ont été installés hier et avant-hier
entre le trottoir et cet immeuble est là
mais ça vous donne une idée la situation
géographique de tout ce qui se passe et
vers le fond de l'image là vous voyez
peut-être un peu moins bien mais il ya
ce quart monde camionneurs cette
intersection rideau au sexe où il ya
encore énormément de camions même si des
policiers ils ont dégagé les camionneurs
ont fait plusieurs arrestations les
camions ils sont encore là parce qu'il
faudra évidemment les remorquer pour
pouvoir ouvrir la voie si là où on en
est pas triste en ce moment les
policiers depuis ce matin vous avez vu
le reportage notre collègue laurence
martens a commencé aux environs de 9h ce
matin des interventions policières
disent plutôt aux environs de 8 heures
ils ont gagné peut-être un kilomètre
depuis ce temps là ils ont un repousser
les manifestants d'au moins 2 karma mais
il reste encore toute la rue wellington
à remonter vers le parlement qui est
derrière nous et aussi plusieurs
intersections quant au delà d'une
dizaine d'interception dans la ville
d'ottawa qu'il faudra investir pour
repousser des manifestants et finalement
les dégager en enlevant les camions qui
sont stationnés
sébastien saint-françois merci beaucoup
pour tout ces collaborations et à très
bientôt merci à votre équipe également
avec nous pour nous donner son opinion
sur cette grande opération policière
marc parent que vous connaissez ancien
directeur du spvm ses parents
alors on l'a vu on veut le revoir sur
les humains
les policiers ont décidé d'être très
patient et que ça ça va prendre deux
trois jours au s'il le faut mais on y va
lentement mais sûrement simple sol
oui absolument méthodiquement et je
crois que la stratégie est tout à fait
responsable et éthique aussi ce qu'on
veut c'est le minimum de violence donc
une seule la force aussi qui ne vient
pas si on veut provoquer justement
peut-être plus de résistance pour
l'instant donc ça se déroule très bien
selon le plan possiblement qu'avait est
établi et de cette façon là aussi on est
en mesure de pouvoir jouer sur
l'endurance du manifestant parce que
bien évidemment il ya le climat qui joue
aussi à travers une intervention de
cette envergure là donc c'est une
approche qui est tout à fait le
pragmatique qui est sur le plan
opérationnel c'est une bonne stratégie
vous en avez vu d'eau des manifestations
monsieur parent sont était à paris je le
disais plus tôt sont à chicago à new
york ailleurs fait longtemps qu on
aurait vu peut-être la police chargée
donc le fait de ne les crs à paris je
pense une évidence le fait de ne pas
charger qu'est ce que ça dit sur ce type
d'opérations policières
au départ pour pouvoir ne pourra être
exempts en mode de plus dynamique ça
prend plus de policiers et l'on ne
l'arrangent avoir énormément de
ressources policières on a même des
ressources en deuxième ligne en relève à
la chaleur dans ce ca permet justement
de pouvoir prendre son temps et d'avoir
une approche qui beaucoup plus on veut
le basé sur
une sortie faisait donner le temps aux
gens de pouvoir quitter éventuellement
c'est la grande distinction aussi qu'on
peut mettre en place à ce stade ci parce
que c'est pas toujours que les corps de
police vont avoir le soutien de leurs
collègues
limitrophes est donc dans le contexte
actuel on a pris plus de temps pour
planifier les interventions
définitivement beaucoup de ressources
pour prendre son temps et éviter les
irritants chimiques évitez aussi une
dispersion plus dynamique il ya sept
camp policier impliqué il ya plus de
mille policiers on n'a pas le chiffre
exact après les ottawa ne le donne pas
évidemment mais on selon nos sources les
yo plus que mille policiers impliqués
adhérents comme vous il ya des gens qui
vont se réchauffer qui revient
coordonner tout ça donne une idée de
l'ampleur de la préparation derrière un
but parce que déjà pourra dire c'est
simple c'est loin d'être simple c'est
très complexe c'est très complexe si ce
n'est que de simplement s'assurer
d'avoir pour chacune dont des unités
d'intervention combleront le on veut
déployer sur le terrain d'abord une
certaine uniformité d'avant la même
intensité aussi parce que on veut que
cette approche là elles soient
uniformisées sur l'ensemble du périmètre
dans lequel on interdit et toute la
planification de bi coordonner
l'ensemble des groupes l'hébergement de
ces groupes toute la logistique aussi
des arrestations
lorsqu évidemment une fois qu'on prend
en charge les personnes sont accusées
par la suite détenu pour comparution ou
à être lancée avec citations à
comparaître de toute une logistique mais
l'on n'est plus que plusieurs
organisations policières et plusieurs
intervenants donc définitivement que
c'est un travail qui est colossal
c'est peut-être pour ça aussi qu'on a
attendu plusieurs jours voir se mettre
en place une telle intervention mieux
coordonnés je pars à elle dans quel
contexte ça pourrait déraper y aurait ou
on pourrait être témoin de gestes plus
viola du côté des policiers
mexes ça dépend de la définition aussi
que l'on donne à déraper
définitivement que
on va peut-être voir une approche un peu
plus
vigilant durant les prochaines heures à
la tombée du jour il peut y avoir des
actes criminels qui vont être commis des
méfaits toutes sortes d'incidents qu'on
ne peut-être pas vu le durant le jour
parce que la nuit on est un peu plus un
peu plus clandestins on voit moins ce
qui se passe donc je m'attends peut-être
à ce genre de soirée où est ce que les
policiers responsables à avoir d'autre
choix que d'être beaucoup plus sont
fermés peut-être une fusée dégagent les
éléments chimiques ou avoir une approche
beaucoup plus qu'à ce bâton et de
boucliers parce qu'on voit parfois les
policiers se retire avec les 15 qui vont
se reposer au relais des points forts
d'une forme relativement vide
normalement donc ce jeu là le
remplacement qui s'exécute mais
définitivement que s'il ya des actes
criminels commis nous des gestes posés à
l'égard des policiers ou de des citoyens
où l'on parlait des chevaux tout à
l'heure à ce moment là on peut voir une
escale usage de la force était important
ce que vous dites parce que les on a des
seins en tête de gaz de policiers qui
font cela avec équipé avec leurs
matraques et tout ça pour arriver vous
dit si jamais un groupe de manifestants
commencent à lancer des choses par
exemple sur les policiers
il faut pouvoir l'utilisation des
irritants chez mais comme une approche
plus violents il faut peut-être le voir
plutôt comme une façon d'intervenir pour
dissuader si on veut la résistance et
nous permettent de progresser et de
dispersible de démembrer les noyaux durs
donc ça peut permettre aussi d'avoir
moins sorte d'adversité et d'avoir moins
de solutions justement de temps record
de deux coups de matraque comme outil et
puis j'irai même exemple au niveau des
chevaux ainsi qu'un cheval représente un
grand nombre de policiers accepterait à
lui seul mot par le ratio qui balaie
d'un à dix 1 1 2 dans la came dans ce
qui veut dire que jusqu'à maintenant je
trouve qu'on utilise des moyens qui
permettent de garder cette espèce de ce
pas cela raison des tensions plus
raisonnable avec la force minimale je
donne en vous remerciant je donne un fer
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure il n'y a eu
aucun blessé rapporté chez les
manifestants jusqu'ici depuis ce matin
un seul policier blessé mais de façon
mineure à la main apparemment et et ce
cheval peut-être lors j'ai pas de
nouvelles du cheval blessé un
manifestant relancer une bicyclette
aurait tenté de lancer une bicyclette
dans ses pattes marc parent on va suivre
ça merci beaucoup de nous avoir parlé ça
me fait plaisir bauer loire
et après la pause on veut faire un petit
panel parce qu'il ya le contexte
politique derrière tout seul la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence est ce que c'est
elle nécessaire pas nécessaire on n'a
pas dans trois minutes
ce qui nous motive ce qui me passionne
en fait en russie c'est l'énormité du
pays un pays énorme par sa géographie et
par son propre politique les stops et
qui polarise beaucoup mais qui passionne
en tout cas laisse personne indifférent
moi la première
personnellement j'ai toujours été
fasciné par la société américaine qui a
des façons pense est complètement
différent c'est pas juste des démocrates
et des républicains les américains c'est
beaucoup plus que ça nos correspondants
notre ouverture sur le monde
votre tour c'est un espace où vous
pouvez être vous même
elle mérite d'être bien protégé
imaginer la vie sans interruption
imaginez les jeux sans attente imaginez
le diabète sans piqûres quotidiennes ou
doit cesser d imaginer voici le système
fui ce temps libre de la surveillance
plage du glucose avec alarme optionnel
qui vous avertissent dès que le taux de
glucose est trop élevée ou trop bas
maintenant on indiqué chez les personnes
de 4 ans ou plus une façon simple et
pratique de mesurer le taux de glucose
une nouvelle liberté essayer
gratuitement le système freestar des
brodeuses amont freestyle.ch
pas si cher grâce à pcas hautement
monfils ou une manche plus de légumes il
voulait une nintendo switch chez
pharmaprix et sachant comment fonctionne
la flip qui est obtenu j'ai vu qu'ils
ajoutaient des choses dont le panier est
qu'à la maison il finissait toujours son
assiette merci chan c'est bon d'avoir
des objectifs est de manger des légumes
c'est comme ça qu'on va encore
s'améliorer des choix santé à
l'accumulation de points spéciaux ping
[Musique]
l'univers harry sont des motions les
milliers de jeux innovants sport préféré
où que vous soyez quel que soit votre
sport trouvez votre pari sur ton est
bête point net c'est tout naturel de
faire du bacon pour tout le monde et
d'espérer personnes en prennent pour les
vrais moments des jeunes et ça prend de
vrais aliments c'est pour ça que le
bacon naturel de maipo leaf effet sans
engrais artificiels
c'est tout naturel
se rétablir de la pandémie signifie
rebâtir une économie qui apporte un
soutien à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
vous pouvez accéder dès maintenant à des
programmes de soutien financier ciblé
fait pour les propriétaires
d'entreprises admissibles et les
canadiens qui en ont besoin
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut bâtir une
économie plus résiliente
consulter canada.ca barres obliques le
coronavirus pour connaître les
programmes de soutien financier qui vous
sont offerts un message du gouvernement
du canada
il y a ceux qui restons neutres et ceux
qui ne s'arrêtent jamais
qu'ils ressentent le besoin d'avancer
sans aucun répit
et qu'ils réinventent ce qui peut l'être
jusqu'au bout
c'est ce qu'on appelle quand on avait
dessiné le gmc terrain et eux ce sont
les gens pour qui on l'a fait
voici le tout premier gmc terre et à t4
et le terrain et l'évasion redessiner
votre maison c'est un espace où vous
pouvez être vous même
elle mérite d'être bien protégés
alors des images en direct toujours de
cette opération qui vont se poursuivre
plusieurs jours en tout cas plusieurs
heures encore tahoua à moins que tout le
monde décide de partir en même temps ce
qui serait surprenant là les
manifestations devant château laurier
avec nous le chef de bureau à ottawa
madeleine les moribonds soit madeleine
stéphanie chouinard du sens politique
que collège militaire collège militaire
royal
et sébastien bovet notre chef de bureau
à québec bonsoir à vous trois d'abord
soir un bout sur le type d'opération
qu'on ne choisit madeleine parent s'est
dirigée par la police d'ottawa mais il
ya six corps policiers autour d'eux
important le mythe on a mis vraiment
toute la gamme les gardes plus de mille
policiers pour monsieur parents nous
disent c'est intéressant plus honni de
policiers ou plus on peut se permettre
de ne pas utiliser de force d'être
patient d'exercer de la retenue mais en
essayant quand même d'avancer de façon
progressive surtout de ne pas faire de
sur place évidemment cet idéal s'y
opposent violence ci ait pas de
dispersion si on n'utilise pas des gaz
si on n'utilise pas des canons à eau
parce qu'on est quand même tout près
d'un quartier résidentiel et seuls les
résidents d'ottawa nous l'ont rappelé au
cours des 22 derniers jours et était
exaspéré de voir les manifestants a
finalement occupé leurs quartiers
résidentiels
donc la police fait preuve quand même de
beaucoup de patience je vous dirai pas
président ça c'est opération aujourd'hui
oui je compare avec ce qui se fait
ailleurs ce qu'on a vu il ya eu des
manifestations anti mesures sanitaires à
bruxelles aux pays bas touchant
stéphanie donc le modèle d'intervention
canadien différent là oui on a
l'impression que ça a été beaucoup mieux
organiser ça a pris quelques jours quand
même depuis
l'annnonce de la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence mais on a l'impression qu'une
belle collaboration qui est établi sur
le terrain entre les différents corps
policiers et effectivement on y va ou
pas on a voulu faire attention aussi aux
enfants qui sont toujours sur place qui
ont parfois été mis directement entre
les manifestants et les corps policier
donc une raison supplémentaire pour que
les policiers aillent de façon prudente
et politiquement politiquement batterie
c'est le scénario idéal pour justin
trudeau se dire que qui ait pas
d'affrontement pas de confrontations là
où ça pourrait devenir un cauchemar
c'est si il ya des gaz lacrymogènes et
des matraques des nez cassé des gens
blessés
ç'a bien été jusqu'à maintenant mais je
nous mets en garde
on a fait peut-être le boul plus facile
en 11 heures de temps ça quand même pris
aux heures pour se rendre jusqu où ils
sont rendus les policiers et il reste le
bout le plus difficile probablement les
irréductibles à déloger donc c'est pas
gagné d'avancé il ya eu une centaine
d'arrestations la police le confirme
pascal robidas nous disait nous les
montrer cette file de gens arrêtés dont
plus d'une centaine en fait une centaine
et plus donc les faisait que la tête
dirigeants l'état dirigeants de ce
mouvement là ont été arrêtés madeleine
oui ils ont été arrêtés j'ai
l'impression que c'est devenu aussi très
publique quand ils ont été arrêtés ils
ont fait des vhu pratiquement des vidéos
sur les médias sociaux donc si les têtes
dirigeantes sont colas a pas empêché
quand même les bd des manifestants de
vouloir rester sur place comme si j'ai
pas nécessairement d'autorité le qui
guidait tout ce mouvement lors dans un
seul bloc alors tour de timbres rapide
sur cette fameuse loi sur les mesures
d'urgence c'est fanny chouinard vous
nous disiez plus tôt le chef de police
d'ottawa donne un coup de main je
trudeau ou là aujourd'hui oui
effectivement donc en point de presse un
peu plus tôt aujourd'hui le chef belge a
annoncé que selon lui si ça n'avait pas
été des trois niveaux de mesures
d'urgence qui avait été annoncé au
niveau municipal provincial et fédéral
qu'on n'aurait pas été en mesure d'avoir
l'opération qui est en cours à tahoua
aujourd'hui donc une façon de donner un
coup de pouce au premier ministre
puisque on sait qu'il ya des détracteurs
il ya beaucoup de questions par rapport
à l'utilité réelle d'invoquer la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence invoqué pour la
première fois et où il ya quand même
plusieurs zones grises madeleine budget
elle est sûrement utile paix les
policiers nous le disent depuis
plusieurs jours et elle et elle
absolument nécessaire comme vous disiez
utile oui parce que c'est possible par
exemple de réquisitionner des remords
que c'est possible de j des comptes en
banque c'est possible de désigner des
sites où c'est illégal de se rassembler
on peut citer c'est sûr nécessité c'est
une autre question et ça justin trudeau
je suis pas certaine qu'il a réussi à en
faire la démonstration lorsqu'il a
plaidé devant le parlement sa cause se
déballonne hip hop n'est pas complétée
mais on attend la suite à quand la suite
ça va dépendre finalement de ce qui se
passe dehors pour voir si les
politiciens vont pouvoir entrer au
parlement donnait une petite parenthèse
pendant que l'opération va se poursuivre
ottawa sébastien boucher voit québec il
ya une autre manifestation prévue demain
oui on se prépare et quand même une
assez bonne présence policière ce soit à
québec il ya quelques manifestants qui
ont commencé à arriver mais on veut pas
répéter les erreurs de t'avoir on a eu
du succès il ya deux semaines la
manifestation à québec c'est pas
incrusté il règlements municipaux été
modifié vous verrez pas de spa à québec
vous verrez pas de barbecue non plus en
principe pouvait pas de comment s'ériger
non plus donc des policiers sont prêts
mais ajoute on sait qu'une manifestants
ont bien fait ça aussi il ya deux
semaines et il invite la population à
une magnifique manifestation festive
alors on verra comment ça se passe beria
laisse présager que ça va glisser dérapé
madeleine stéphanie sébastien merci
beaucoup de vos analyses merci à très
bientôt au revoir
alors mesdames et messieurs que penser
de ce qu'est ce que vous pensez de tout
sens de cette opération policière
voici nos adresses
[Musique]
alors il ya eu la neige que c'est ce qui
a aidé ou pas les policiers on verra y
en aura d'autres demain oui il y avait
un pochon à trois noms oui effectivement
mais demain ça va remonter mais il ya
autant de neige de maintien de vue
durant la soirée
après 20 il ya cette perturbation qui
passe là bas il ya de la neige pourrait
tomber de façon assez soutenue mais
debout brièvement mais ça va passer
quand même durant la journée et encore
des avertissements de poudrerie le seul
extrémiste du québec des précipitations
sous forme de pluie abondantes et des
vents violents sur terre neuve mais dans
l'ensemble ça s'est calmé toutefois sur
les prairies on aura des temps perdu et
mon fils tués par mallet sur winnipeg en
ce moment les des vents forts et la
poudre est donc un avertissement de
blizzard qui se relever quand même
durant les prochains heures toutefois
parce qu'il est cette perturbation
apportant des précipitations va passer
assez rapidement donc ça laisse à peu
près 5 cm en moyenne de 5 à 10 pour la
région de québec par exemple vers les
laurentides ça passe assez rapidement ce
qui fait que pour la journée dimanche on
a de la neige au nord 5 à 10 cm vers
l'abitibi témiscamingue au sud du repos
grand chose des flocons alors pour
montréal il ya des neiges passagère
demain il y aurait des percées de soleil
en après midi mme ça pourrait tomber de
façon soutenue héros du vent aussi avec
cinq centimètres dans l'ensemble 5 à 10
vers l'outaouais et les laurentides et
dimanche auprès des flocons qui est le
deal des températures douces québec cinq
à dix centimètres d'eau mais des vents
assez forts en après midi laisse très
peu près 5 cm ainsi que la mauricie ça
pourrait tomber de façon soutenue en
après midi l'abitibi-témiscamingue de
même un petit peu de neige mais dimanche
5 à 10 cm saguenay-lac-saint-jean à peu
près 5 cm demain sur la bo 5 cm possible
demain surtout une après midi mme bas
salaires à peu près 5 à 10 cm possible d
sur la gaspésie 25 cm essentiellement
l'après-midi à côte nord quelques cm aux
îles de la madeleine c'est plutôt
tranquille avant l'arrivée de la neige
prévue dimanche n'a pas grand chose
quelques centimètres les maritimes beau
en nuage mans l'après-midi en europe
après cinq centimètres dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche et par la suite
éclaircies région te retourner
températures vont remonter comme vous le
voyez et les prairies 5 cm possible sur
winnipeg demain je des températures par
la suite même situation sur l'origine et
sur la côte du pacifique arrosé de mes
petites améliorations partir de dimanche
merci beaucoup passé on se retrouve
lundi mesdames et messieurs 1re div a
évidemment suivre les événements
d'ottawa au cours des prochaines heures
de les voir des images et le tyran
téléjournal malgré des généreux
téléjournal à 22h sur la première chaîne
alors oui rd 24 60 euros l'édition
spéciale ça se poursuit on nous dit nos
experts jour et nuit pour combien deux
trois quatre jours les paris sont
ouverts on verra madame et messieurs
merci de votre attention
nous on se retrouve en principe lundi à
17h merci à très bientôt dans toutes les
caisses
[Musique]
la technologie cno antho nous offre un
monde de possibilités incroyables mais
ces appareils finiront tous par devenir
dessert plus rien un jour vous en avez
certainement quelques un prêt à être
recyclé mais avec tous les choix de
recyclage qui s'offre à nous on pourrait
être mêlée pour vos sert plus à rien il
n'y a qu'une chose à faire les apporter
dans un point de dépôt officiel pour vos
sert plus à rien c'est au point et
[Musique]
vendredi 18 février ce soit à 24,60 une
édition spéciale de deux heures
consacrées à l'opération policière en
cours pour mettre fin au siège d'ottawa
non
s'il y avait eu une action concertée je
pense qu'on n'en serait pas rapide
nous ne prenons aucun plaisir à un
bouquet ces mesures
[Musique]
quelques moments forts de cette journée
de cette opération policière en cours
mais là messieurs bonsoir bienvenue à
cette édition spéciale de deux heures de
24,60 qui va évidemment porté
entièrement sur cette opération
policière parce qu'on cherche à mettre
fin à cette occupation du centre ville
d'ottawa quand même après 22 jours de
siège on se demande quand et comment ça
va finir quels seront les conséquences
sociales et politiques de ces événements
vous avez en ce moment sous les yeux des
images en direct où ça semblait calme
mais il semble qu'il ya eu de
l'agitation ya pas si longtemps on a
réussi aujourd'hui elle
diminue et le territoire occupé par les
manifestants de la libérer donc un grand
périmètre
la police confirme plus d'une centaine
d'arrestations plusieurs camions sont
partis librement sans heurt sans
protester mais d'autres irréductibles
tiennent bon tenir bon c'est impulser la
version française de leurs slogans oddo
line et dans les dernières minutes il ya
eu du brasse camarade alors on rejoint
sur le terrain où un journaliste pascal
robitaille sébastien saint françois on
voit justement les chevaux le bon soir
sébastien on va voir pascal ou si on
n'est pas très bien en ce moment mais
d'abord je commence avec vous c'est
baissier peut vous le dire un peu la
situation à l'instant même
et au centre-ville d'ottawa de marie les
policiers ont regagné beaucoup de
terrain par rapport à ce que les
manifestantes de m ce matin je vous
montre la scène en ce moment on est tout
juste devant le château laurier sur la
rue rideau la rue rideau est se
transforme derrière doit ruminer ça
monte ça jusque devant le parlement à
environ
700 mètres maximum sinon oui tous ces
policiers qui forme évidemment une
chaîne y mettre 3 profond à certains
endroits et des centaines de
manifestants devant rue très proches
certains qui essaient d'en reparler
certain que les invectives
et ses policiers là il regagne du
terrain pas à pas depuis maintenant à
cet endroit c'est aux environs de 16h30
donc oui il ya eu des moments de tension
certainement dis moi où on se demandait
ce qui se passait et depuis je vous
dirais environ 30 voire 40 minutes
dépressif on opposera permis entre
autres de remplacer les agents qui est
en première ligne aux côtés ou sous
l'image que vous voyez environ 40 de ça
c'est un bout de la ligne qui était
tenue par les agents de la sûreté du
québec qui était qui sont arrivés en
renfort maintenant ce sont des agents de
la ville d'ottawa qui sont sur ce bout
là de la ligne est ce son des
percussions qu'on entendait des
manifestants des tambours oui parce que
à certains endroits de la ligne il ya un
peu une atmosphère de fête anne-marie
quand on n'est pas en moments de tension
de pression entre les policiers les
manifestants il y en a qui jouent de la
musique draps qui a même de la musique
des radios pré enregistrés il ya un an
ce moment vous l'attendez ou lampard dès
qu'ils le jouent du tambour donc sa main
plus d'atmosphère en travail peut-être
que ça réchauffe un peu les gens parce
que je fais en ce moment très froid on
est dans les moins 20 peut-être un peu
plus haut vous avez peut-être vu passer
un tableau rapidement marie une carte de
la ville d'ottawa
landreau on se trouve en ce moment
l'endroit où on se trouve en ce moment
de marie c'est pour que les gens
comprennent ce qui se passe c'est dans
la deuxième ronde que les policiers
veulent dégager qu'ils ont presque
réussi à dégager on a subdivisé le
périmètre est maintenant bouclée dans le
centre-ville de 3 une dizaine de zones
et les policiers aujourd'hui ils ont
réussi à en dégager deux mêmes quand
même vous êtes là depuis ce matin vous
avez vu des changements vous avez vu une
évolution compte la journée ces bassins
ouais tout à fait ce matin c'est le voir
sur les images qu'on attendait pour vous
pendant de longs moments sur la
promenade colonel by un peu plus bas
en droit on se trouve cela vraiment où
les manifestants ils ont affronté pour
la première fois les policiers
d'affronter parce que ils ont refusé de
bouger ont formé des chaînes humaines
des fois avait des renforts 2/3 de
profond ça donnait de lui des saintes
quand même surprenante où les policiers
repoussant les manifestants gagner du
terrain pape a presque au corps à corps
il ya eu en bon québécois coup de pouce
à yazoo paraître pardonnerez
l'expression ça fait des mairies qui
ressemblait des fois dire et les de
rugby il ya eu plusieurs arrestations à
ce moment là entre quinze et vingt
arrestations ce moment-là de marie et
sas a duré plusieurs heures jusqu'à ce
que les policiers réussissent à
rejoindre première interception et
dégage les camionneurs qui devra les
gagnants sont toujours là cette première
intersection la mêlée kamenar eux ont
quitté où ont été arrêtés les le
changement depuis ce soir apparaît si
l'utilisation des policiers à cheval
service de police de toronto qui ont été
amenés ici en renfort ce soir
aux environs de 17 heures on a eu droit
à deux mouvements de chevaux de cette
cavalerie municipal pour séparer la
ligue des manifestants de celle des
policiers ça automatiquement ça
provoquait beaucoup de romans beaucoup
de réactions de colère la part des
manifestants très clairement les
policiers ou les ménages et une zone
tampon qu'ils ont rapidement occupées
pour gagnant contenu de terrain utilisé
s'étendre là deux fois et arrive un
incident plus lors de cette manoeuvre en
plus de l'ère de la charge en fait de la
manoeuvre les policiers qui en a surpris
plus d'un ben il ya un manifestant qui
aurait selon service de police d'ottawa
tenté de blesser le cheval se manifesta
là il a été arrêté un des six des huit
chevaux se manifestant là il a été
arrêté il fait face à une accusation
justement d'avoir tenté de blesser un
animal de service qui peut s'appliquer
aussi dans le cas je suis au passage
deux chiens qui sont en service mais
dans ce cas ci qui est utilisée dans le
cas d'un cheval qui on aurait tenté de
baisser on le voit image à l'instar
ces policiers qui vient de prendre la
relève des essais de la saison est-ce
que vous avez une petite idée du moment
où le peuple
l'opération pourrait prendre fin
c'est une très bonne question de marie
ce qu'on constate en ce moment c'est que
les policiers sur une dizaine de zones
ils ont réussi à en dégager deux
seulement et on n'est pas encore arrivé
au noyau le plus dur des manifestants
qui devant la chambre des communes le
parlement sur la rue wellington donc je
pense qu'on peut présumer sans trop se
tromper que ça va prendre au moins
24 heures de plus sinon peut-être 36 ou
48 heures parce qu'en plus de samarie
foutu liés lorsque les policiers
réussissent à dégager par exemple
intersections qui tenus par les
camionneurs et par les manifestants les
camions restent là il faut ensuite ni
remorqué s'assurer qu'ils aient pas de
varices afrique et pas de bris des
remorques à l'extérieur de
l'intersection et s'offrent un avis au
minimum une quinzaine des perceptions
comme ça dans la ville de dà voit donc
je pense qu'on peut présumer que ça va
prendre au moins 24 heures sinon 48
heures de plus à tous dégagés et
redonner leur vie leur centre-ville pour
l'instant d'autres merci beaucoup et ça
va faire une fête en cours d'émission
sonore jusqu'à 21h pour courir cette
opération policière me tourne maintenant
vers faciale rueda pascal les policiers
ont arrêté
plus d'une centaine de manifestants là
oui absolument et c'est un bilan qui
risque de grimper au cours des
prochaines heures la raison pour
laquelle je vous mentionne ça c'est
qu'on était nous à l'arrière-scène d'où
se situe sébastien saint françois et
dans les autobus d'oc transpo il ya
actuellement des dizaines de
manifestants qui ont été arrêtés
menottes aux poignets au cours des
dernières heures on leur a lu leurs
droits on leur a lu également les chefs
d'accusation qui risque d'être déposé au
cours des prochaines heures contre eux
on les garde en détention on les
transporte un peu plus loin dans un
autre endroit où ils seront rencontrés
par entre autres des policiers de la
première police provinciale de l'ontario
est également de la gendarmerie royale
du canada en fin d'après midi peu après
la charge de la cavalerie dans le groupe
de manifestants c'est à ce moment qu'il
ya eu le plus d'arrestations
la fil a pratiquement quintuplé en moins
de 30 minutes et c'est à ce moment là qu
on a vraiment senti que la manoeuvre des
policiers donner des résultats en faut
dire qu'ils sont restés statique pendant
quand même une bonne partie de
l'après-midi en simplement regardant les
manifestants scandaient des slogans
liberté en brandissant des drapeaux
canadiens et en fait citoyen mais à un
moment donné les policiers on a senti
qu'ils ont perdu patience et ça s'est
soldé par des dizaines d'arrestations
et en fait je la vois la file d'attenté
ne pas l'amener à fait de l'arrestation
le pendant que vous nous parler elle est
impressionnante et les gens doivent être
frigories gilles parce qu'ils attendent
longtemps avant qu'on prenne leur
identité imagine alors que c'est en
effet fait froid et pascal ils ont
arrêté quand même des leaders du
mouvement 2 hier encore pendant qu'on
faisait notre émission la première
l'arrestation de deux d'importants liens
mais aussi arrêté packing paquin c'est
pas n'importe qui
c'est l'un des principaux leaders de
toute l'organisation
ici même à ottawa du blocus vous avez
raison hier avant cette opération
policière qui a débuté vers 6 heures du
matin on a mis en état d'arrestation
chris barber qui a d'ailleurs été
relâché en fin d'après midi qu avoir
comparu devant
devant la justice est également tamara
leach qui a été l arrêté hier soir et
finalement pas de king lui on l'a
cherché quand même un petit moment
aujourd'hui et on l'a finalement mis en
état d'arrestation
il a quand même eu le temps de
s'adresser aux manifestants par sa page
facebook en direct à deux reprises et
finalement on l'a mis en état
d'arrestation menottes aux poignets donc
les trois principaux organisateurs avant
de sonner la charge contre le groupe de
manifestants ont été arrêtés par les
policiers marie on est plus ajouterez
pascal que selon nos collègues de
cilicie l'autre organisateur la réponse
est mal son nom le dit chaude et une à
lui quitté ottawa puissant le tigre
donné une entrevue attaque karting sur
fox news donc il aux gens de rester de
risque et s'est arrêté mais lui s'en va
alors ce sera à suivre j'imagine
oui absolument et il faut dire que les
gens les écoutant
on peut parler en quelque part dans une
forme de deuil parce que se voyait
rester ici jusqu'à ce que la vaccination
obligatoire prenne fin il ya quand même
plusieurs revendications en marge de la
pandémie de coved 19 et ils seront
délogés bien avant d'avoir atteint leur
objectif
les gens sont en colère nous mêmes notre
équipe on s'est fait apostropher devant
le château laurier en après midi faut
dire que les médias les relations que
les manifestants les médias c'est
difficile sur le terrain il ya une
confiance qui est de toute évidence
effrité alors les gens ici avec les
événements qui se sont produits
aujourd'hui et qui les attendent au
cours des prochaines heures seront
définitivement très émotif et ils ont en
laissant également très motivé en
terminant de garder la ligne rester sur
place comme on les entendait petit cc
sont les irréductibles parce que
d'autres ont accepté de partir notamment
un camionneur dont on avait bloqué le
compte en banque ou qu'on risquait de
saisir le camion benne prenez la route
alors pascal on se reparle tout à
l'heure vous nous fait signe d'ici là
s'il ya des développements majeurs
avec l'usure et l'on voit marc parent
qui est de nos invités pour but de
comprendre cette opération policière
surtout la stratégie parce qu'on connaît
pas trop ça nous on en a vu
quelques-unes au fil de l'histoire du
québec le thierry bourgeois et était
avec nous également ce soir bonsoir tous
les deux écoutez j'aimerais avoir votre
évaluation appréciation est ce qu on
sait à quoi on a assisté aujourd'hui qui
n'est toujours pas terminé ma part
on le sait que plein de matches je crois
que c'était l'intention lors du
commandement unifié chef de police
d'ottawa d'avoir une approche qui était
très nerveuse et vaguement c'est qu'avec
ont coiffé tous deux l'occasion on a des
centaines et des centaines de policiers
sur le terrain qui permettent d'avoir
une approche avec la force minimale
requise donc à cet égard là je crois
qu'ils font un excellent travail de
pouvoir graduellement progresser valeur
objective de reprendre possession d'un
sens belle image mais définitivement que
jusqu'à maintenant ils sont vraiment
très indisciplinée j'ai dû beaucoup de
policiers aussi dans différentes
situations qui restait très quand même
aucun geste isolé donc on voit qu'on
vous les règles d'engagement est
vraiment une bonne préparation mentale
ou super trouper sur le terrain alors
bravo pour ça et pour vous un péril
bourgeois
l'appréciation
mais moi je regarde votre garde aux
côtés de la médaille je regarde du côté
des protestataires ti qui s est dit que
carradine terre il ya deux volets et moi
c'est faso c'est le volet évidemment des
mesures de santé publique qui a créé
beaucoup de frustration il ya de ces
gens là j'écoutais ce après midi ski ski
lancé aux policiers aux menaces et ces
termes et ces gens leur parler aussi de
leurs pertes d'emplois donc beaucoup
d'émotion au niveau des manifestants et
c'est dans ce contexte là que les
policiers demeurent quand même
de glace et qui ils continuent à faire
leur plan match en respectant le droit
ces journaux d'exprimer leur frustration
l'autre volet aussi qui est quand même
important c'est que c'est ces gens là
aussi manifestants l'on croit
sincèrement à leur droit de manifester
et que l'intervention policière
pour eux et est un affront à leurs
droits démocratiques selon eux de
manifester
évidemment eu trois avertissements peau
les manifestants de comprendre qu'il
s'agissait maintenant d'une occupation
mais il est évident que ces gens ne
croient fermement qu'ils ont plein droit
d'être au centre-ville de fer bois et
continuer à manifester il ya ces deux
volets la du côté des manifestants qui
évidemment créé cette situation bord de
l'eau et comme martin indiqué des
policiers gardent de plans marque et
avancent de façon très systématique moi
parce qu'on va y revenir au cours de
cette émission avec vous avec d'autres
invités parce que la revendication de
liberté se fait au détriment de
centaines de citoyens qui ont aussi
perdu leur emploi leur gagne pain on
pense au centre rideau qui est fermé
depuis trois semaines les commerçants
ont raconté on peut entendre des
témoignages de gex de manifestants dans
les lobes et d'hôtels ou de masques en
fumant au mépris des autres au mépris de
la liberté des autres donc c'est aussi à
prendre en compte quand on parle d'une
opération assez lentes j'ai dit en guise
mais parce que bon et méthodique marc
parent est ce qu'on peut se poser la
question on a vu des images on peut
peut-être avoir encore le tout près du
château laurier on a déjà fait une
cinquantaine d'arrestations mais là on
est toujours devant un face à face entre
des manifestants les policiers y at il
une raison qui fait qu'on les arrête pas
eux aussi puisqu'ils sont dans une zone
rouge une zone désignée illégal
mais je crois qu'on essaie de travailler
de façon intelligente chacune des
sections du périmètre pour garder un
certain contrôle est aussi une femme de
lies for me tais et d'avant la même
intensité et puis le fait d'avoir
beaucoup de policiers sur le terrain
permet justement d'avoir une approche
plus loin en utilisant pas d'autres
moines y est peut-être plus haut un
muscle et où on pourrait par exemple
julie temps chimiques ou à toute forme
d'apports plus le plus musclé donc je
crois que le fait d'être plus patient
aussi comme vous dites pour certains
endroits permet de travailler avec
peut-être le facteur psychologique donc
l'endurance des manifestants à rester là
cette fronde d'opposition là alors que
des petits mots et relativement froid
les ressources position au loin une
alternance les gens vont se reposer les
pôles si policières sont en mission et
quand on est en mission je peux vous
dire par expérience que normalement on
va livrer la marchandise
il va s'assurer de faire le travail de
façon professionnelle jusqu'à fin qu'on
a atteint notre objectif en dessous si
ça joue en la faveur et seulement la
défense policiers et manifestants se
sont rassemblés spontanément sans mais
il ya eu une guerre psychologique mais
aussi car durant ce que logique
actuellement que et je me suis qu'un
rapport de force à sénégal là dessus
c'est voulu bourgeois parce qu'on a des
centaines et centaines de policiers qui
peuvent se relayer au bout de quelques
heures notamment à cause du froid de la
fatigue la tonne aline l'attention et
des manifestants etc sont pris dans son
cher ceux qui sont dans le château
laurier ils peuvent pas les nuls par là
sont debout dans le froid qui peuvent
pas ne peut pas décider d'aller dans un
hôtel ou un restaurant du coin là
exactement c'est que y'a une information
de déploiement des policiers sur le
terrain recchi il amène de façon
méthodique les manifestants vers le
devant du parlement sur la rue
wellington et un effet d'entonnoir qui
va se créer et éventuellement les
manifestants d'avoir les décisions à
prendre
c'est à dire que je demeure ici au
risque d'être arrêté ou je décide que je
quitte les lieux et c'est ce que
évidemment le déploiement policier sur
le terrain a hissé l'objectif prisme un
conte vis de résolution pacifique d'une
situation qui quand même les explosive
non elles sont arrêtées et sont le
remets ma part en une citation à
comparaître madame lire shadows a été
remise en liberté notamment adorons les
conditions depuis allez sur les résoudre
enfin j'aimerais souvent les conditions
qui lui ont imposé mais de palets sur
les réseaux sociaux et répété son
message tenu bon au dollar je mangeais
non on va partir du point où
effectivement puis évidemment il va y
avoir une approche très ce qu'il sait
que particulière pour les leaders ceux
qui ont été beaucoup plus actif ils sont
vraiment l'affiché une foule de
renseignements comme des acteurs clés
qui ont vraiment amener l'eau ce niveau
2 ont de manifestations le haut niveau
qu'on connaît actuellement il y aussi
les manifestations les manifestants
pardon sur le terrain qu'ils eussent
exposé à d'autres sites d'infraction
donc évidemment on va traiter à la pièce
le selon leurs rôles qu'ils ont joués
depuis le début de la planification de
cette manifestation là et aussi leur
présence sur les réseaux sociaux et sur
le thème qu'est-ce qui fait est tous les
deux pays d'abord vous monsieur
bourgeois qu'on a choisi ce ce type de
stratégie de lens mais de tickets
presque pacifique là à comparer à
d'autres sociétés
en lice à l'europe on pense aux états
unis d'ailleurs les gens la sûreté du
québec avait même ordonné aujourd'hui
leurs masques à gaz donc on avait quel
message on veut envoyer en ce moment par
une opération menée de cette manière
plusieurs via plusieurs blessures je ne
peux pas m'empêcher de regarder
l'histoire
à travers le temps ici on regarde
simplement des sous quinze dernières
années quand on parle ça ou sommet des
amériques à québec
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là bord toute
la dynamique qui entourent lgv à toronto
alors que les policiers avaient exercé
une méthode qui était plutôt musclée qui
résultent et à des poursuites de passe
différents individus contre le service
de police de la ville de toronto pour le
montant total de 6 millions de dollars
donc il ya des notions qui ont été
apprises ont fait du temps et le
déploiement policier tel qu'on le voit
aujourd'hui est le résultat ces notions
apprises là pour éviter ou 30 et de
chercher la solution le plus la plus
pacifique possible puisqu'en bout de
ligne ce qu'on recherche c'est justement
d'éviter tout débordement une toute
confrontation toute violence évidemment
lorsque il n'est manifestants pose d'une
certaine direction les possibles c'est
la direction opposée mais on recherche
quand même 7 cette résolution leur est
assis on regarde plus ce qui se passe en
france lors de manifestations ou
ailleurs dans d'autres parties du monde
je pense que la méthode canadienne a
évidemment un peu plus bas mais ça cause
beaucoup moins de dommage parce que leur
police au canada ce une police
communautaire par la suite s'il
policiers leur devons vivre avec ces
jeunes est précisé que te parler
monsieur bourgeois que je vais finir en
quelques secondes avec mais ses parents
avant de vous retrouver l'un d'eux maire
de l'émission je suis de la génération
qui se souvient du samedi de la matraque
à québec dans les années 60 dont la
visée de laruns et le 24 juin 1968 la
police était pas mal moins patiente su
par an on peut au peut plus vivre ce
genre de situation non mille et une
évolution si lien puis avec le dit le
modèle de police canadiens à l'ensemble
du canada est une approche de police
communautaire de proximité de
concertation et je me suis en 2012 une
demie grande préoccupation était de
préserver c'est nier la avec la jeunesse
parce que des milliers de principes
aussi accéder c'est comme ambassadeurs
et ambassadrices opère la jeunesse donc
c'est tout à fait vain quand il dit de
préserver sa miellat parce que ses
citoyens canadiens et on va continuer à
les côtoyer donner ma faim tout à fait
d'accord avec lui et notre modèle
policiers un modèle de mme hollis
heidsieck basée sur une approche damas
avec usage minimal et sa rivale vais
peut-être depuis 2002 aussi parce que
quand même des images qui étaient
difficiles à regarder et puis tous les
deux on se retrouve en deuxième heure on
va continuer d'analyser la situation
merci de votre temps et votre expertise
à tout à l'heure
au retour le ministre de la justice du
canada d'avis de l'amitié la loi des
mesures d'urgence etait-elle démontrer
était-elle nécessaire
cette semaine l'émission on vous parle
du
[Musique]
xi a plus d'occupation illégale c'est
plus de blocus il ya plus d'objets pour
voter pour cette loi là le npd on
pourrait considérer
voter autrement dans ces situations
l'exigent je crois pas que la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence a été l'élément
déclencheur de cette opération qu'on a
ce matin chose certaine c'est bien de
voir que les policiers font en sorte de
libérer la rue wellington s'il y avait
eu une action concertée des forces
policières avaient
avec une classe politique qui aurait
pris rapidement ses responsabilités et
le jeu vise particulièrement le bandama
fédéral parce que senna sakho mais je
pense qu'on n'en serait pas traduit là
vous l'entendez les partis d'opposition
sont contre la loi des mesures d'urgence
le npd qui a donné son appui pourrait
reconsidérer cet appui tout à l'heure je
vais m'entretenir avec le chef du npd
jack meeting mais quelle est la réaction
du gouvernement trudeau à ce que la loi
était si nécessaire qu'est ce que les
événements que l'on veut aujourd'hui
montre son utilité mon invité le
ministre de la justice monsieur david de
l'aneti et procureur général du canada
bonsoir monsieur la multi bien menée 24
60 bonsoir madame dessous alors avec ce
que vous voyez vous avez tenu un point
de presse aujourd'hui pour expliquer
selon vous la nécessité l'utilité de
cette loi mais avec ce que vous voyez à
tahoua ayant entendu les commentaires de
l'opposition en quoi la loi était
nécessaire pour démanteler le siège à
ottawa
mais c'était nécessaire non seulement 3
mai à travers le pays en tant qu' en
tant que législateur nous avons la
responsabilité de fournir les outils aux
forces policières à travers le canada
avec avec les lois avec avec les les
pouvoirs nécessaires pour faire ce qu'il
faut faire ce qu'on avait trouvé en été
et on était engagé dès le début soit en
alberta soit au manitoba et en ontario
on a on a identifié des lacunes si vous
voulez dans les pouvoirs les les
pouvoirs que les polices ont su gérer
nécessaire et donc on l'est on a comblé
si vous voulez les lacunes avec la loi
sur les urgences avec des mesures
temporaires des mesures mesures et des
mesures ciblées et ils sont en train de
fonctionner ils ont eu un impact tout de
suite le lendemain après la promulgation
de la loi
le blocage ou à un mersen a été
débloquée parce que les un moment donné
les remorqueurs étaient présents et qu'
il n'était pas présent donc on peut pas
on peut pas tirer un lien causal
trop étroites trop étroit mais quand
même ça eu d'impact sur le comportement
des
ddd camionneurs et des des caméras des
le des remorques qui
un moment donné sont devenus présents et
parent comme trame comme avant donc et
on voit aujourd'hui on a on a entendu
les forces policières ici à trois
messieurs belge qui a dit que la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence leur a aidé
aujourd'hui à faire ce qu'il fallait
faire et donc on voit je crois
l'application de les mesures qu'on vient
de promulguer temporairement avec
vraiment les avec la complicité des
forces policières à travers le pays nous
avons donné les ressources les outils
aux forces policières ils sont en train
de les employer un sondage publié hier
de marie public opening qui dit que 66 %
des canadiens appuient les la loi des
mesures d'urgence mais 90 pour sa part
qu'on dit qu'on n'aurait pas dû se
rendre l'oeuvre ce fut la perspective de
l'opposition que au fond cette loi là
c'est une forme d'aveu d'échec devant
les mesures qu'on aurait pu prendre
avant que la situation ne s'aggrave
qu'en pensez vous
on comme j'ai dit long à une division
assez strictes au canada entre les
décisions rationnelles de la police et
les lois
moi j'ai l'obligation de promulguer les
lois pour promulguer une loi ça prend
beaucoup de temps sauf dans un cas
exceptionnel où on est on arrive au
seuil de l'emploi de la loi sur les
maisons d'urgence on est arrivé à cela
on a décidé après après mûre réflexion
d'aller de l'avant avec les
consultations des provinces ecce terra
on a rempli nos obligations sous la loi
qui n'est pas une loi facile à employer
mais on l'a fait mais on on a au début
travailler avec les provinces pour
s'assurer que les ressources nécessaires
étaient avec les forces policières dans
chacun
des fois il faut suivre cette étape à la
lettre pour arriver à la bonne
conclusion mais aussi un conclusion qui
est justifiable alors ce test est la
première fois qu elle est utilisée cette
loi là
donc là le parlement ne siège pas le
passé j'ai aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a
un bug que laisse entendre enfin des
conservateurs que laisse entendre qu on
se renvoie vers une autocratie parce que
le parlement ne siège pas alors que tous
les partis s'étaient entendus pour qu'il
ne siège pas aujourd'hui est ce que le
parlement va sièger demain pour que
possible oui oui mais cette réaction
cette réaction complètement démesuré
complètement exagéré mon dieu c'était
une décision qui a été prise par le
président de la chambre en consultation
avec les livres des parties et est donc
on va on va reprendre demain c'était une
demande de la police locale pour ne pas
mettre qui que ce soit un en danger donc
c'est pour la sécurité de tout le monde
non seulement nous mais aussi no no no
équipe donc complètement exagérée la
réaction d'une console avec cette
opération policière en cours on pourrait
croire que d'ici 24 à 48 heures ottawa
sera libéré dès mai des manifestants
qu'arrive-t-il si le mtd reconsidère son
appui et ne votent pas en faveur de la
loi que la loi est rejetée n'est pas
adopté qu'arrive-t-il à tous ces gens
qui ont été arrêtées en vertu de cette
loi là et qui vont être accusés en vertu
de cette loi là
je vais pas entrer dans les hypothèses
et madame de sauce que je tout vous dire
nous allons en tant que gouvernement
procéder avec la loi
défendre la loi justifier la loi
jusqu'au moment et et garder la loi en
vigueur jusqu'au moment que la pays le
pays soit sécurisé ce n'est pas tout le
temps évident donc oui pas de blocage à
windsor mais on vient de lire hier que
les polices locaux des polices locales
ont arrêté un autre tentative de bloquer
le pont donc on doit sauver la situation
on travaille avec les forces policières
à travers le pays on va regarder ce qui
se passe en fin de semaine on va
regarder ce qui se passe en fin de
semaine à travers le pays
et un moment donné on veut nous aussi on
veut
terminer l'application de la loi
aussitôt que possible j'ai dit
publiquement que l'on ne voudrait pas
voir la loi pour une jours de plus mais
il faut il faut faire attention donc on
va travailler avec la télé on va vers la
situation et j'espère que nous allons
prendre la bonne décision quand il faut
prendre le bon de jouer parce que ses
ventes en du monsieur boulerice puis
j'aurai monsieur signe tout après vous
dans leur esprit si l'opération est
terminée la loi n'est plus utile donc
cela loi n'est plus aussi plus qu'une
hypothèse parce que dans vos discussions
il faut voir les conséquences d'une
décision du npd ce la loi n'est pas
adoptée à ce moment là tout ce qui a été
fait en vertu de cette loi là depuis
deux jours devient illégal sont juristes
la plus commune et je pense que je
m'adresse sur quoi de loi
évidemment les déclarations on était
légale pendant le temps qu'ils étaient
sains force et donc c'est au parlement
de le faire de regarder la loi d'une
façon exposé facto c'est la structure la
structure de la loi il y demande nous
allons parler avec les [ __ ] nous nous
allons rester en communication avec eux
avec les conservateurs avec le bloc
aussi je crois qu on sincèrement malgré
malgré des fois l'hyperbole des
conservateurs et d'autres nous voulons
garder
le pays en sécurité et donc on partage
cette excuse moi je tourne et ses
conservateurs qui ont décliné une
demande d'entrevue mon a vu les
gazouillis tweets de monsieur poilievre
non aux mesures d'urgence stockwell day
and ans quand même dans ces
conservateurs qui fait la comparaison
avec la place tiananmen en 1989
et madame bergen qui est dit qu'elle est
choquée de ce qu'elle voit
à tahoua que c'est le pm qui recrée la
situation
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ce qu'on voit
sur le terrain on voit sur le terrain
des occupations
l'organisation
à travers le pays qui a des liens à
d'autres organisations à travers le
monde avec le financement au coût de
financement de l'étranger avec avec des
idées assez
anti démocratique et donc faut souligner
et vous l'avez dit vous-même il faut
souligner que ce n'est rien à faire avec
la liberté d'expression nous avons
protéger la liberté d'expression même
dans cette période où la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence est en vigueur ce sont
des blocages ce sont des occupations qui
empêche les personnes de vivre leur
sécurité leur emploi leur vie
quotidienne l'économie canadienne s'est
on peut pas je dois dire que c'est une
manif à 6,7 une occupation très égoïste
les gens qui s'en fout des droits des
autres ce n'est pas la tradition
canadienne s'est pas légal non plus
alors là dessus monsieur le ministre la
médecine merci d'avoir été avec nous je
comprends vous serez au parlement demain
que le le débat va se faire et le vote
peut-être lundi ou mardi on verra la
suite du calendrier merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci beaucoup au revoir et au
retour la réplique du npd avec son chef
jack mincing et le bloc québécois avec
christina michaud sont mes invités reste
avec nous
voilà ce qu'ils font aux aborigènes loin
de l'image de carte postale pour mouler
nature c'est le quart monde alors que ce
sont nos terres loin de l' eldorado rien
n'est fait pour réinsérer les jeunes il
s'agit seulement de nous briser c'est de
le faire disparaître à travers mes
enfants en effaçant notre héritage
l'australie révèle son plus grand tabou
de plus en plus d'acteurs politiques
assume publiquement leurs idées racistes
on ne va pas abandonner comme l'ont fait
les blancs en afrique du sud tout ça va
beaucoup trop noir racisme la face
cachée de l'australie aux grands
reportages mardi 20h is ir dit
bonjour comment allez vous aujourd'hui
est ce que je peux vous aider
besoin d'être écoutés nous sommes là
telle aide saguenay-lac-saint-jean 1 8 8
8 6 en aide saviez-vous qu'au de
pharmaciens de famille peut vous aider
pour certaines conditions qui semblent
plus compliquées comme
d'encore brandon taux de sucre oui on
peut rendre sa simple hockey
pharmacienne famille proche de votre
santé carbone nouveau bâton de loin
si philippe
ses futures j'ai économisé gros en
combinant assurances habitation et auto
en ligne avec ceux nés cinq petites
minutes droz économies assure yvon en
ligne sur scène et point serre n'est ce
pas avec la porte lui
[Musique]
vérifiez votre cote de crédit
gratuitement au crédit qu'armand point
ca pourrais pharmaciens de famille ça
prend d'empathie qui aujourd'hui j'avais
une migraine mon sixième sens
reposez-vous on voulait votre
prescription au cul
pharmaciens de famille proche de votre
santé
le président des états unis joe biden se
dit convaincu que le président russe
vladimir poutine a pris la décision
d'attaquer d'ukraine la policière de
minneapolis y avait eu un automobiliste
noir en disant avoir confondu son
pistolet électrique et son arme de
service a été condamné à deux ans de
prison de la santé publique fédéral
évoque la fin des restrictions de plus
sévère grâce à la vaccination et
l'augmentation de l'immunité collective
le coût du projet d'agrandissement de
l'oléoduc trans moncton acheté par
ottawa en 2019 a presque doublé à plus
de 21 milliards de dollars et l'apport
supérieure du québec confirme la
validité des 25000 demande d'exclusion
du recours collectif intenté contre les
écoles privées du grand montréal
[Musique]
eric pour les assurances le gab les
rénovant les cinq fois plus vite avec me
claude c'est le futur à quai mais est-ce
que techland sont capables de nous faire
économiser en achetant nos assurances en
ligne avec son 5 petites minutes grosses
économies assurez-vous en ligne sur ça
n'est point c'est à se rétablir de la
pandémie signifie rebâtir une économie
qui apporte un soutien à ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin vous pouvez accéder dès
maintenant à des programmes de soutien
financier ciblé fait pour les
propriétaires d'entreprises admissibles
et les canadiens qui en ont besoin
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut bâtir une
économie plus résiliente
consulter canada.ca barres obliques le
coronavirus pour connaître les
programmes de soutien financier qui vous
sont offertes le message du gouvernement
du canada
c'est pas parce qu'un problème de santé
urgents qui n'est pas grave
moi j'en pouvais plus d'attendre ma
douleur était insupportable
c'est pourquoi j'ai choisi de faire
confiance au réseau lacroix j'ai enfin
pu avoir accès la chirurgie dont j'avais
tant besoin grâce à leurs blocs
opératoires privé à la fine pointe de la
technologie
plus question de ma santé se repose
choisir la croix chirurgie privé c'est
avoir accès rapidement à des chirurgies
en neuro chirurgie orthopédie
gynécologie orl et puces les décrypteurs
samedi 11h30
ici a dit quoi qu'il arrive le sous
titrage cette émission vous est présenté
par fidelity investments vous travaillez
fort pour prendre les devants
informez-vous sur fidelity pour vous
aider à rester à l'avant garde
[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut être prudent et
d'avoir les outils si jamais par mégarde
il y avait des gens qui avaient idée de
faire d'autres occupations comme celle
là on est tous les moyens pour
évidemment prévenir
alors le directeur du service de police
d'ottawa dit que toutes les mesures qui
ont été mises en place et est nécessaire
d'ailleurs vous voyez le cordon de
policiers ce sont toujours des images
enduits en direct des manifestants
décidés à tenir bon à répondre à l'appel
de leur leader qui leur dit de tenir bon
au domaine c'est le slogan on verra
comment la soirée évolué nous sommes
avec vous jusqu'à 21h les partis
d'opposition
croit-il toujours que la loi sur mesure
d'urgence n'était pas nécessaire pour
mettre fin à l'occupation du centre
ville mon invité est le chef du npd
monsieur jack meeting au soir monsieur
5000 nouvelles 4,60 bien sûr mais aussi
beaucoup alors on veut on veut
comprendre votre votre opinion à ce
moment ci des événements opérations en
cours monsieur bell dit que la loi était
nécessaire les politiques ont interview
également monsieur la médecine vous
venez d'entendre également
qu'en pensez-vous vous après avoir vu ce
que vous avez vu aujourd'hui
puis comme on a dit j'ai dit que notre
parti va appuyer les mesures d'urgence
et cette application avec et réticences
parce que ce n'est pas un moment de
fierté pour notre pays c'est vraiment
une exemple delà de la manque de
leadership et c'est un échec de
leadership le fait qu' on est rendu dans
cette situation mais si importants qu'on
reconnaître que reconnaît que ce groupe
ce convoi cette occupation ces gens ont
des idées contre la démocratie leur but
bien partagés sur le site web c'est et
de renverser le gouvernement ils ont
attaqué les gens ils ont ciblé les
résidents c'est quelque chose qu'on ait
jamais vu les manifestations normalement
cible les gouvernements et leurs
décisions
ce groupe ce qu'on voit cette occupation
a ciblé les résidents les familles les
enfants et les gens qui portent des
masques aussi ils ont bloqué des ponts
donc aider frontier et ça ça a fait mal
aux gens aux travailleurs à travers sa a
impacté le travail et plus et personnes
ont perdu des heures de travail des
journées de travail donc c'est vraiment
une menace sur
beau plus des personnes donc on appuie
la décision on va continuer d'évaluer la
situation et comme on a 10 6 et jamais
le cas qu'on pense que les mesures ne
sont pas nécessaires on est près deux
ans lever notre appui et arrêté
l'application de ces mesures je veux que
vous soyez très précis là-dessus
pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous ferait
enlever votre appui à la loi au vote
la décision va être si les mesures ne
sont pas nécessaires ou si le
gouvernement les utilise dans une
manière qui n'est pas approprié donc on
va être vigilant on vas tu jures évaluer
l'application de ces lois et on est près
d'enlever notre appui mais à ce moment
comme on a dit on va on est prêts
d'appuyer là qu'il me semble que c'est
vraiment nécessaire les policiers et les
gens sur le terrain on dit que sans
avoir c'est à ces mesures sans avoir ses
pouvoirs on aurait pu à faire le travail
qu'on a fait donc je veux bien
comprendre votre évaluation de soin de
ne se fera pas devant le fait que le que
le tabac est libéré même si ottawa est
libérée mais si la loi était appliquée
conformément à ses intentions vous
pouvez continuer à l'appliquer mais
disons que demain ou dimanche et
personne ne lui à tahoua libéré etc vous
pourriez quand même voté pour la loi
lundi ou mardi au moment du vote
si parce que si la menace est toujours
là on a vu qu'il y a toujours des
menaces sur les frontier dès qu'on veut
qu'on voit on essayait de encore faire
la même chose je ne veux pas être dans
une situation où on doit réagir après
les frontistes sont encore fermés parce
que c'est inacceptable d'être dans cette
situation je sais qu'il ya des millions
des millions de dollars que ce qu'on
voit et cette occupation ont levé et
s'est vraiment cet outil important
arrêté le financement d'un mouvement qui
attaquent les travailleurs qui est ac
notre démocratie qui attaquent les gens
et je vous écoute que j'ai vraiment
l'impression que dans le fond vous allez
voter pour cette force en clair
jusqu'à ce moment on est prêt de voter
mais comme j'ai dit tu peux changer et
on ne sait pas ce qui va arriver mais
pour le moment notre appuyer là et on va
rester vigilant parce que monsieur là
métier je posais la question tout à
l'heure j'ai dit ce qu'est ce qui arrive
si le npd monsieur lâm et il veut
continuer de vous parler alors monsieur
l'abbé tidou disait quand même que même
si la loi n'était pas adoptée elle est
en vigueur elle est tout ce qui a été
fait jusqu'à maintenant est fait dans un
cadre légal et j'ai présumé légale dont
au fond il veut quand même vous tendre
la main comme parti pour envoyer un
message aux canadiens qui appuient la
mesure selon ce sondage marièrent le 66
% des canadiens appuient la loi des
mesures d'urgence mais pour certains je
pense à l'association des droits et
libertés civiles au canada puis estiment
que le test de ce que sont des mesures
d'urgence et rob ne se serait pas si
grave
pour justifier des mesures d'urgence
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que la situation était grave et
est grave une menace sur de menace sur
notre démocratie
une
idée fait kino frontier été arrêté à
l'impact sur les travailleurs et aussi
le grand impact pour l'avenir si si un
groupe comme ça qui est contre la
démocratie peut encore arrêtée les
frontier a fait mal aux gens ont fait
mal aux travailleurs et travailleuses
sont bien organisés ils sont bien
financés donc s est vraiment en crise
sérieuse et on va prendre au sérieux
cette crise et prendre des mesures
nécessaires pour régler la crise pour
moi ce n'est pas une opportunité de
jouer de la politique de gagner des
points politiques pour moi ces moments
le moment de montrer de leadership le
moment sérieuse sur yeux et je veux
aider pour régler la crise je veux aussi
dénoncé le fait que les conservateurs
aient aussi les libéraux sommes
malheureusement ont joué des politiques
avec ce qu'on voit et avec l'occupation
de mon avis du moment d'être prudent
pour aider les gens et pour régler une
crise
votre en terminant quelle est votre
appréciation de l'opération policière
jusqu'à maintenant qui semble se
dérouler de manière
lente méthodique et même pacifique on y
va avec une stratégie
bien coordonnées
je pense que jusqu'à ce moment intitulé
rapport est ce que j'ai vu c'est
vraiment une approche
sérieuse ferme et juste akroud on a donc
j'ai aucune problème jusqu'à ce moment
avec leur approche ils ont bien avisé
les occupations et les gens on va vous
arrêter si vous restez là et ils sont
restés là donc c'était une opération
jusqu'à ce moment qui me semble qu'ils
étaient bien organisés jack médecin chef
du nouveau parti démocratique merci nous
avons parlé ce soir on se reparlera
certainement l'année prochaine leurs
prochains jours merci bonne soirée à
vous merci
je poursuivais christina michaud
porte-parole du bloc québécois en
sécurité publique et député de la
circonscription d'avignon la mitis
matane matapédia bonsoir bienvenue à
24,60 vous aussi je vais demander votre
appréciation de l'opération policière
jusqu'à maintenant
dans sa madame tussauds écoutez c'est
assez incroyable les images qu'on voit
sur vos ongles depuis ce matin et je
salue vraiment travail des policiers des
dix-sept corps policiers des policiers
de la sq lui aussi qui agissent avec une
force de caractère une résilience et bon
contrôle sur eux mêmes quand on voit des
résistants qui veulent des opposants qui
veulent résister justement donc ça prend
ça prend une certaine force une certaine
patience et je salue cette heure on a vu
plusieurs arrestations - depuis le début
de la journée plusieurs voitures chères
camion remorque est alors je salue
vraiment ce travail là il pas eu de
débordements jusqu'à maintenant et c'est
positif on a vu des rues un peu plus
dégagé le notamment un en face du
parlement en façade et l'utilisent la
confédération alors on espère que tout
se déroulait dans le calme et le pack
city west on va continuer notre
évaluation avec nos invités marc parent
et il lui arrive bourgeois tout à
l'heure en deuxième heure bien que votre
parti
ne soit pas d'accord avec la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence bien qui a une motion
unanime de l'assemblée nationale pour
exclure le québec pardon est-ce que vous
reconnaissez que
la loi était nécessaire pour mettre fin
à l'occupation
je pense pas que ce soit nécessaire pour
appliquer une loi de dernier dernier
recours n'a pas été évoquée depuis son
adoption en 1988 c'est la nouvelle
mouture de ce qu'était la loi sur les
mesures de guerre qui a été évoquée
vraiment en raison de crises nationales
les deux guerres mondiales la crise de
1970 là on est dans une situation où bon
le centre-ville d'ottawa bien entendu et
ciblée mais à travers le pays on sent
pas vraiment qu'une urgent un état
d'urgence ou une crise nationale alors
faut faire attention avec ce genre de
loi là je pense pas que une loi spéciale
par exemple n'aurait pas pu faire le
travail ça aurait très bien pu le faire
mais prend mettra en fonction ou mettre
en place certaines mesures qui auraient
pu permettre l'oeuvre d'aller remorquer
les véhicules par exemple où les camions
je pense que ça aurait pu très bien
faire le travail et c'est pas la
première fois qu'on voit une
coordination entre les corps policiers
en des services d'urgence des pompiers
dans les codes si nice notamment où des
corps policiers qui sont raides je pense
qu'on aurait très bien pu faire le
travail sans évoquer cette fois là qui
nous apparaît assez extrême mais qui est
clairement une mesure de dernier recours
à une mesure de dernier recours d'autant
que cette loi telle que la situation
d'urgence et d'écriture tous les
blocages les frontières on désigne
certaines zones il ya toutes les mesures
économiques également qui semble avoir
eu un effet très dissuasif sur certains
est-ce que là ça rend pas nécessaire ou
utile de cette loi mais les images que
je vois depuis ce matin à la télévision
ça me rappelle beaucoup celle que j'ai
vue la semaine dernière ou pas
ambassadeur alors que les policiers ont
prévenu qu'elles travaillent sans que la
loi sur les mesures d'urgence soient
appliquées alors quand on a des gens qui
sont coordonnés qui sont prêts à faire
face à une situation mais je pense que
ça peut très bien fonctionner et se sont
demandés depuis le jour un gouvernement
fédéral de créer une cellule de crise
non seulement avec les homologues
provinciaux les maires les différents
corps policiers mais d'être coordonnés
d'avoir un plan de match et surtout
d'envoyer un message aux mains restant
ben vous avez droit de manifester mais à
partir du moment où la forme de votre
manifestation devient une égale mais y
aurait des conséquences alors on l'a
très bien vu à la ville de québec les la
ville les corps policiers ont pas laissé
les manifestants s'installer tout s'est
bien passé alors je pense qu'on aurait
pu très bien nager votre rang sans
évoquer cette loi-là qui encore une fois
je le dis c'est une oie ses sérieuses
dernier recours et et ça crée un
précédent qui peut être dangereux pour
l'acheteur en même temps le premier nice
de l'ontario là soit elle invite elle et
les manifestants à quitter you désiré du
cube qu'est-ce qu'on fait selon vous
avec ces irréductibles qui tiennent bon
en ce moment devant les forces de
l'ordre mais je pense que les forces de
l'ordre contraignait le travail en ce
moment on est vu des gens qui ont été
arrêtés je pense que ça va se poursuivre
dans les prochaines heures s'il ya des
gens qui sont très réfractaires ou qui
veulent utiliser la force ou pas que ce
soit je pense que les forces policières
ont tous les outils en main
normalement c'est pas les outils qui
leur sont données par la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence nécessairement je
pense qu'ils ont tout en main pour pour
intervenir pour agir de façon le plus
pacifique possible on l'espère sans que
la force soit utilisée mais quand même
s'il arrive à une situation où on est
joueur un peu peut-être 23 ans par le
comte ça aurait dû passer bien avant et
on est tous d'accord que ça aurait dû se
passer bien avant qu'on aurait dû
nettoyer si vous voulez bien la rue
wellington et le centre-ville d'ottawa
parce que on entendu les manifestants et
on entend encore des commentaires de
gens qui disaient vous auriez dû aller
les écouter les entendent et je pense
que le gouvernement aurait pu faire ça
mais pour ce qui est des oppositions je
pense qu'on a pris le temps d'entendre
les revendications et on voit la
situation changer à travers les
provinces de le dévoiler un plan
concerne de déconfinement les
conservateurs sont allés au devant de
ces gens qui expriment un discours de
haine et de mépris
même la croix gammée enfin est-ce qu'on
pouvait aller s'asseoir et écouter des
gens qui étaient aussi radicaliser
annonce a pris une toute autre forme ça
c'est certain au début on parlait les
camionneurs qui qui était content la
mesure à la frontière pour la
vaccination obligatoire et et s'était
même pas la majorité des camionneurs et
coutumes du saumon père et camionneurs
ils y croient faire vacciner et l'autre
lui aussi bon qu'on soit sorti de cette
pandémie l'homme et fait ce qu'il faut
et je pense que le gouvernement en
général le gouvernement du québec par
exemple avec des ressources internes mis
en place en fait ce qu il croyait le
mieux est une situation extraordinaire
ce qu'on voulait c'est protéger la
population et on comprend qu on comprend
qu une grogne mécontentement mais je
pense qu en faudrait cent je suis passé
de l'ironie mais ces camionneurs là qui
voulait mettre fin aux passeports
vaccinale qui est une entente avec les
états unis donc symétrique en d2 de côté
s'ils se retrouvent avec un dossier
criminel va il prend pas y aller aux
états unis de toute façon
alors là tu madame michaud merson coup
bonne soirée à vous merci à vous d'avoir
pour retourner l'intervention des forces
policières puisque cette opération est
en cours ont fait le point avec vos
invités au retour en deuxième heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
alors des images en direct sont les
images que vous voyez en ce moment ça en
ce moment c'est quand ça n'a pas bougé
depuis depuis tout à l'heure en fait le
cordon policier
hélas les manifestants sont là c'est
extrêmement calme c'est un peu festif
ailleurs nous et pascal robidas tout à
l'heure ce que les images que vous avez
vu avant ce sont des images des moments
forts de cette journée c'est une
opération policière qui a commencé bon
début d arrestation hier mais vraiment
ce matin avec l'entrée massive de
policiers dans certaines zones
repousser les manifestants les
concentrés dans une zone particulière
faire plus d'une centaine d'arrestations
tout ça dans un calme un calme c'est
qu'un contrairement à ce qu'on vous
n'aurait pu appréhender d'une opération
policière d'envergure devant des gens
qui sont assez déterminé des gens qui
veulent tenir bon alors je joins à
nouveau mes invités marc parent et père
yves bordier a alors un bon soir à vous
deux on va poursuivre notre conversation
de tout à l'heure je pense que ça n'a
pas bougé qu'est-ce que ça envoie ce que
ça faisait que c'est une pause pour la
soirée et la nuit sa période bordure
je serais bien surpris qu'on parle de
pause pour la nuit il est certain que
les policiers comme ça s'est produit un
peu plus tôt cet après midi il ya une
pause d'environ 1 heure ou deux pour
justement voir et jauger un peu comme un
vil la folle était pour réagir on
espérait qu'il y avait certaines
personnes parce que c'est un calme
relatif était porté ce qui s'est
produite par la suite il ya un mouvement
de foule vers les policiers y avait une
pression additionnelle de micron plat
ligne de front et c'est à ce moment là
qu'une intervention la cavalerie de la
police de ville de toronto pour
justement à briser un peu cette
pression-là et et créer un espace qui
permet aux policiers d'avancer assez
rapidement il est certain qu'avec le
froid avec la combinaison de la fatigue
des des manifestants les policiers vont
pouvoir peut-être est en mesure de
gagner du terrain assez rapidement au
fur et à mesure que la soirée progresse
il ya aussi le fait que les policiers
leur son
ni plus ni moins hard et à des
changements pour fois se reposer refaire
leur énergie revenir parce que du côté
des manifestants mais c'est les mêmes
individus qui demeurent lot donc il est
certain que la fatigue doit s'installer
et les policiers vont peut-être profiter
à ce moment là d'une ouverture pour
pouvoir gagner plus rapidement du
terrain ce qui est aussi fascinant c'est
de voir à quel point ce que 100 mètres
de là une atmosphère festive et oui
déroule comme s'ils s'y habitue de marié
qui se passe bon ça ça veut dire quel
message envoie en manifestant sa marque
pas c'est que les manifestants aient
réduction savent bien que les policiers
vont y aller étape par étape mais qui
continue à
être festif la musique les tambours là
dedans c'est tout ça marc parent
est-ce que c'est roland ont font enlever
de trudaine on va être patients parce
que c'est trop la non mais il faut
nécessairement ce sens que moi de voir
un groupuscule qui plus festif qui est
allé quand ils ont de l'eau ça passe un